It's,
I don't know,
we're not really on youtube,
but we're on ustream right now.
Bitches are we on?
We're on right now.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the link for the
flashlight,
you get 15 percent of the number one sex
toy for men.
Also want to thank Joel servers,
jolt servers of the ones who are hosting
us.
That's Jason's company.
And uh,
he's a cool motherfucker.
Got a good friend of mine and uh,
also on it.com.
Makers of Alpha brain.
And uh,
if you go to Joe Rogan.net,
or if you go to Alpha brain,
whatever,
if you go to [inaudible] dot com as we
gotta do.
Oh and it o n n I t put in my name Joe
Rogan or grow.
Just put.
Rogan says,
listen to this dude,
I don't really know what the fuck I'm
saying.
You forgot to take Alpha brain today.
Didn't you know the three of them right
before the show?
They just haven't kicked in yet.
I wonder now,
we just,
we just smoked way too much weed.
Here we go.
The Joe Rogan experience.
We just mixed a bunch of Shit,
man.
We mixed some shit called moon rocks and
with some other stuff.
Was Moon rock sativa or was that also.
There's an Oji indigo Jesus.
A deep couch lock weed.
And then we mixed it in with that other
stuff.
No,
no.
Susko Hannah today.
You brought up the big.
I had to get around.
We didn't bring out that orange where
that blueberry orange from 2005 and not
fucking right.
I got it right away.
It was the best shit back in 2005.
It was,
it was before train wreck when I first
started buying weed before we had a,
um,
before we had licenses,
I would always buy mass quantities
because I didn't want to have to deal
with those dudes,
but I always had just laying around.
Dude,
it was incredible.
It's a funny subject.
This marijuana and there's a lot of
controversy behind it and I'm not given
in.
I'm tired of it.
It's a stupid topic.
It's a bunch of people.
For whatever reason,
care about what other people are doing
and is always the same tired ass fucking
argument about what about children.
You're setting an example to the
children to what?
To what?
To eventually be a person who's an adult
who enjoys marijuana.
That's life.
That is real life.
Like why are we have to pretend that
that's that to hide that and you,
you parent your fucking kids and don't
let them do anything until they're in
their twenties.
I don't think kids should be getting
drunk.
I think you barely can keep your fucking
shit together as a teenager,
as it is emotionally,
psychologically to get drunk on top of
that.
I mean,
I did it.
I know you did it,
but it's a terrible idea.
If I was going to be honest with my
kids,
I would say don't get drunk,
don't get high,
don't do shit while you're developing.
Beat.
Become uh,
a man first.
You know,
I,
people ask me why I'm so vocal about it
and the reason I'm about it is
because I can get thrown in jail for it.
So I'm going to be vocal about it until
there's absolutely no possibility that I
can get thrown in jail.
And this is for the kids too.
I'm fucking making a stand here.
You are making a stand here in the
future.
By the time the kids are 18,
19,
20.
Hopefully it will be legal.
So we're doing this for the kids.
But you know,
I'm a big fan of Coca Cola.
I love coke,
but I never talk about it.
But if it was illegal it was illegal to
drink soda and you can get thrown in
jail for it.
I'd be talking about it every goddamned.
I'm like,
I'm drinking this fucking soda.
I'd be videotaping me drinking soda.
It's okay.
Why are we being thrown in jail?
Look,
I'm a productive guy drinking coke.
But you know what?
It's legal.
I'm not talking about it.
And when weed is legal 100 percent all
the way through,
I'm gonna.
Shut the fuck up about it.
Watch.
I'm not going to shut up about it.
I,
I.
It's a positive thing and that's what
people aren't willing to accept.
So many people want to think that it's a
negative,
it just shows a negative image or it
sends a negative message that you need
something to get through your life with,
and that's not what anybody is saying.
You don't need it.
You don't need it,
but it's good.
It's that sense.
It's the wonder drug for me,
like instead of taking tylenol off,
smoke some weed,
instead of doing this weed is so safe
that if you smoke too much,
you might call the cops on yourself.
You're not going to call the cops on
yourself.
If you do a lot of heroin or you get too
drunk,
imagine getting too drunk and you're
calling the cops on yourself on weed.
You'll call the cops on yourself
sometimes,
you know?
Yeah.
Weed is the safest of all of them and
it's the most introspective evolve them.
You know,
alcohol doesn't make an introspective.
It makes you an asshole,
but weed makes you like sensitive about
the things that you're saying.
It makes you more aware of when you're
being socially awkward.
You know,
you feel the sting of,
you know,
weird shit coming out of your mouth.
Whereas when you're drunk,
you don't give a fuck,
it just comes back.
It just pours out.
You know?
It's,
it's an amazing thing that so many
people believe different and yeah,
it could fuck up your life.
There's people that didn't smoke pot and
become losers,
but guess what?
They would have been losers anyway.
That's really what it is.
And it's like what you're saying is the
lazy people with no ambition who aren't
that bright pop gets a hold of them.
It's gonna make it's gonna fuck up their
life.
Well guess what?
Their life has already fucked up.
If you let you know you,
you come to certain roadblocks or
certain things in your life where you
have to sort of make decisions about
your behavior,
where you sort of have to reassess
yourself.
And if you can't get through the weed
hurdle,
really how the fuck are you going to
deal with the real world if you can't
get through the hurdle of weed?
Because weed to me is the truth.
That's what it is when I smoke pot.
Yeah,
I can say a lot of silly shit and I know
you get weird and started talking about
the universe,
but what it is to me is the truth.
Anything that's bullshit,
anything that's a lie.
Anything that's blatantly misleading
when you're high
is just glaring,
like acting is glaring.
If you go to see a movie high and
they're bad actors,
it's gold layering.
If you watch a political speech when
you're high,
it's glaring.
You feel the bullshit where you like,
what the fuck am I listening to?
It's offensive to you.
People have the wrong impression,
man,
and it's.
It's a shame.
It really is a shame.
It's not that everyone should do it.
You don't have to do it,
but you shouldn't be upset if someone's
telling you an honest interpretation of
the positive experiences they have on it
and people will go,
well,
you know,
what do you always have to talk about?
It's fucking annoying.
Oh,
you guys ever fucking talk about his
week because there's still people out
there that are arguing against it.
There's still people out there that
don't get it.
It's a personal choice issue.
You're a human being and it's the most
Republican of all ideas.
Stay the fuck out of my private life.
Stay the fuck out of my personal life.
Don't get,
let government get too big.
Well,
this is exactly what this is.
This is only something that's being
pushed into illegality by gigantic
corporations is the only way in this day
and age that it would still be illegal.
There's,
there's resistance because people are
making money with it being illegal.
It's that simple.
And when you look,
you look at the,
like the movie reefer madness.
It was made back in the thirties.
It was produced by the government.
And if you look at that and you see
where it all came from and all came,
that was the beginning
was actually made by alcohol companies
in the beginning,
in the beginning.
Um,
they,
they try to scare everybody by saying
that we'd major kill and major crazy.
You'll jump out of windows.
You'll kill people.
They made lots of movies.
They made a whole bunch of them in the
thirties.
That was the reefer madness propaganda.
It worked.
Any negative negative thought you have
about weed,
it stems from that propaganda from the
thirties.
There's,
it's not a conspiracy theory.
There's many movies out there that you
could watch.
You could watch them on youtube.
That's where it started.
The reason why they don't say that,
you know,
you go crazy and you jump out of windows
and you kill people and all that shit
anymore is because people got hip to it.
They believed in the thirties and the
forties.
But then,
you know,
people were,
were smoking weed in the fifties and
sixties.
They were like,
it's not making me crazy.
This is actually pretty cool.
So they had to change their stance
slowly.
It evolved from weed kills you to weed
makes you worthless,
you know,
that's,
that's all because you know,
they have a lot of examples because
there are a lot of potheads who are
worthless,
but they're just worthless people.
You know what I mean?
So they just focus on that.
Any negative thought you have for weed
and marijuana?
It's because you.
We've all been brainwashed.
I used to be the biggest weed hater ever
until I was 28 my whole life.
I couldn't stand potheads.
They made me sick.
I was just like,
all those guys on the underground were
writing all that shit.
I would have been doing that.
I would have been doing the same fucking
thing.
I was annoyed.
Every band I was in had one or two
potheads they fuck up on stage or they
fuck up rehearsing.
I would blame the wheat.
I go,
dude,
you gotTa fucking high.
You fucking smoking weed.
You can't play bass and smoke weed.
I was so clueless.
I didn't have any idea because every now
and then I get talked into smoking weed
in high.
There was an high school moment.
There was a moment and when I was 23,
24,
that where I freaked the fuck out.
I got all paranoid and I freaked out and
I hated it.
And Weed.
What happens when you're high is it's
like a roaring river of information.
It just flooded into your brain.
Some people don't want to ride those
wild rapids.
They're like,
fuck that.
I'll stay in the tent.
Some people like it's wide,
ride that wild,
rapid and just absorb that energy and
use it to benefit yourself.
Some people,
you know,
when you get paranoid,
I still get paranoid every now and then.
Every now and then that fucking roaring
river.
I don't want to do that.
You know what I mean?
I just,
I just want to.
I'm not into it.
So it's all like the paranoia and you
know,
feeling Irie two opposite ends of the
spectrum.
It's all up to you with the weed.
If you smoke weed,
if you can get paranoid.
If you can't handle all that
information,
you want to suppress a lot of that shit.
Don't get high.
You're.
If you've got a lot of crazy stressful
things on your mind,
things that are making you nervous.
You got to talk to some people but you
don't know how to say you might get
fired from your job or your,
your wife's,
you know,
might be cheating on your whatever
you're thinking about all that shit.
If you smoke weed,
you're gonna.
Focus on that.
You know?
So I,
I recommend that you start smoking weed
around 28,
30.
I never recommend we do kids.
I never do.
I think it's best if you're fully
developed,
you know who you are,
you know what kind of person you are.
Especially if you're an artist,
you have a lifetime of art.
And then at 28 you see how your art
changes every whatever art you do,
it'll change.
So you'll appreciate it.
The later you wait.
I would say wait till 30.
Jack Herrera,
the greatest hip activists out there,
started smoking weed when he was 35.
He was totally anti.
We'd just like me,
just like Joe.
Joe Hated potheads.
We were all just like you all those guys
that think that are fucking throwing up
in their mouth right now and they're
sick of me and joe talking all that.
All those guys,
we were just like,
you smart motherfuckers,
you guys are smart.
But that we were brainwashed by the
motherfucking government.
We were brainwashed.
It's really simple.
So you should be happy that we're trying
to tell you the truth.
Don't deny the truth.
We're telling you the truth man.
And it's not some crazy alien
conspiracy.
This is some real shit.
And by the way,
it's only our subjective truth.
If your truth is different than my truth
of you do part and you don't like it,
like Stan hopes,
townhome just doesn't like wait.
He doesn't like it.
He doesn't like the feeling,
which is fine,
you know,
no one's forcing you to do it.
You know,
the real problem is when people were
upset at other people doing something
that doesn't affect them,
but they get upset at it,
they,
they see that
possible potential weakness in
themselves.
And so they lash out at it when they see
it in someone else.
I really think that's what it is.
You know,
they're,
they're scared themselves that it's a,
it's their future that they could get.
They get hooked on a drug too.
And that's how I look at it.
It's kind of cool it at talking about
mushrooms.
Mushrooms was on a cartoon the other day
on a,
a family guy like Sunday,
9:00,
8:30,
they add,
Brian found a bag of mushrooms and they
showed the mushrooms that looked like
the mushrooms and any aid,
um,
and went onto this huge mushroom trip
and the whole episode was about Brian,
like showrooming,
like the majority of it.
And it was kind of interesting to see
that,
that actually they had that on,
on a regular show on TV.
That was that the first time that,
that may maybe like a primetime show
actually dealt with mushrooms as well.
Simpsons the homer Simpson went into a
chili cook off and eat.
So that was always kind of like,
that was always kind of like,
yeah,
this is like mushrooms,
you know,
it wasn't like him eating a mushroom.
No.
Was it,
it was some sort of psychedelic pepper
member.
And the,
the pepper is made him have these crazy
trips.
It was the most awesome Simpson's ever.
Yeah.
So they've done that before.
You would love this.
I mean,
it doesn't really look,
make mushrooms look great.
Like,
this is not what I see when I,
when I share my,
my Sherman's,
but it's definitely fun to watch.
While showrooming,
I think
there's a new study on mushrooms that
magic mushrooms make you a better person
and it stays with you for awhile.
Like shrugging.
So the thing is John Hopkins,
yeah,
researchers led by [inaudible] mccleon,
a postdoctoral student at John Hopkins
University analyzed personality data on
52 participants,
average age of 46 years old who had
participated in the groups earlier
research on the drug.
These volunteers took siliciden during
to five two to five sessions at various
doses under highly controlled conditions
at the hospital.
They were also given personality tests
before the taking psilocybin and again,
a couple months after each drug session
and then again about a year later.
And so what they're saying is that all
these people have all said that it,
it turns you into a better person that's
there.
It had a positive effect on their
personality.
Think about,
think about some people went unchanged.
It said,
uh,
um,
think about
the fact that,
you know,
a lot of people are saying,
Oh,
you guys are just using the medical
thing.
Just isn't as an excuse to smoke pot.
Oh,
you guys are,
you know,
faking your ailments just to get a
medical marijuana card.
Yes,
we are dumb dumb.
We are.
We have to go through the medical thing.
This is the process of making it legal.
Ultimately there won't be a medical
marijuana,
marijuana.
Just going to be really faking it though
I'm not faking it.
I smoke weed for exactly what I tell a
lot of things.
I'm not saying you,
I'm saying there are a lot of people
would say that would just fake or
whatever.
I'm not saying who,
but I'm just saying yes,
we have get through the medical.
It's a baby steps.
Ultimately it won't be medical
marijuana.
It's just going to be adult use because
now it's not.
It's not just,
it's not just a neutral.
It's actually,
it's not like a vitamin.
It's better than a vitamin.
It actually cures diseases.
It's better than just a vitamin or a
protein.
I mean,
it,
it's,
it relieves glaucoma for instance,
and now they're finding so many,
there's so many studies of,
of,
uh,
you know,
reducing cancerous tumors and all that
shit.
Vitamins don't do this.
This is a magic herb with no side
effects.
There's no side effects.
No one's ever died from it.
Why are you so worried about your kids
doing it?
Don't worry about it.
I'm not,
I'm,
I have a son coming and I'm going to
tell them the truth.
I'm not going to lie to Mama.
Tell him the truth about weed and I'm
going to tell him that he should not
smoke until he's 28 to 30.
Why would you,
why would you want him to wait so long
now so that he could appreciate it more?
There's a lot of young until I was 15
and I appreciate the fuck out of every
time I smoke it.
Not everybody,
but there are some people,
and I've mentioned the best examples.
Well,
I would think like the older you get,
I,
when I get older,
I've noticed I'm more concerned about my
health because your health starts to go
when you're.
You're getting old.
I think if I were to start smoking weed
when I was 30,
I would even be more freaked out.
You say this,
but yet how do you smoke weed and smoke
cigarettes at the same time?
Because I got to think that if you don't
do it on the same time,
I had one in each hand and I just go
from back and forth.
I would think that if I was smoking weed
and I was also smoking cigarettes,
the fact that I was smoking cigarettes
would start to freak me out so bad that
I would quit.
I would realize how ridiculous it is and
how crazy and terrible.
We all know it's ridiculous and terrible
and horrible for your body,
but we're also addicted to it.
It's like any other.
Why don't you just carry around a
packet,
joints and just smoked joints all day?
Because I don't.
I don't.
I'm not like Joey Diaz style.
I like to smoke one or two hits and they
go do something and then later I'll take
one or two hits.
I'm not like I am as well and this whole
fucking joint.
If you raise your tolerance,
a panel wants to,
you can get to the habit.
I don't like being in a cloud.
We'd instead of.
I don't like being.
I don't like being in a cloud.
We'd cloud you mean?
Yeah.
You can get definitely getting a weed
cloud,
especially if you're one of those
wakened biggers,
you know,
he can.
My best of your health's not good.
My Point Brian was,
and I wasn't,
I was saying some people that have been
smoking since they were like 11 or 12 or
whatever.
I know some serious artists are super
creative and uh,
they,
they tell me,
I think you're giving them too much
credit.
I mean,
we just chills me out.
They smoke weed all day every day.
Amazing artists like will,
they just chills me out.
I go,
Dude,
look at your gallery,
dude.
You're the one of the most creative
molly's doing sculptures and you don't
think the weed has.
And it was hard for him to see it
because he was always artistic and he
always smoked weed so he couldn't see
the difference if he weren't a smoked
weed and did all this artistic stuff,
you will still been a great artist I'm
sure.
But that would have been a difference in
the art if you would have been an artist
until he was 28 and then started is art
would have definitely changed.
And what I'm saying is I would be way
more concerned about my kid being an
alcoholic or you know,
getting addicted to coke or something.
Shit.
The people die from,
you know,
again,
I don't want my kids smoking weed at 13
or 14,
but worst case scenario he does.
He does start smoking weed.
It's not going to be the worst thing.
I'm not going to trip out on it.
I'm like,
all right,
fuck dude,
you're smoking weed.
How long have you been smoking?
I go,
you know,
I really think you should fucking cool
it or whatever.
But you know,
when he's an adult will be smoking weed
together.
Watch,
watch.
Are you?
Are we got.
We got,
we got,
we got someone on the line know who's on
the line.
Somebody on the line.
You're going to live.
What's up out there?
Why you call him?
I just think to not speak to any
problem.
No one knows.
What the fuck are you doing here?
Are you going to get an iphone?
Are you going to get the new one?
Dude?
No one knows what the fuck we're doing
this like half a million people and
maybe 10,000.
How do you feel about weed
and I,
I know I've talked to you.
You're live on the air.
Why?
Why,
why?
Why I'm talking to you.
I'm not joking here.
You chose right here Eddie.
I don't want to.
Do you want to just be the podcast?
I even tried to talk some sense for Joe
Hogan.
He's at least I can drop the bad guy.
Alright.
We're going to have to.
We're going to have to cut you off man.
Joe Doesn't want to talk to you.
You don't want to talk.
You know
I'm going to just turn it.
That is the most inside of inside jokes.
That 99 percent of the people listening
to podcasts will not have any idea what
the fuck that is.
So
apple releases the iphone four s today
and it's not the five,
whichever one's thinking,
but remember the three gs when the three
g went to the three gs and that whisk.
That was a real iphone and I think
that's what they're doing here.
Like I think there's going to be a five
maybe around June or so,
but this s isn't that bad.
The cameras,
you're just taking a wild guess.
Well yeah and that's definitely a guest,
but I mean they did it before,
you know,
like the three gs was not.
It was a mild upgrade.
That's why they never caught it.
The Ford,
the three gs added.
What was it?
I don't even remember like a better
camera.
So many rumors about this.
It's,
it's,
it's.
I always feel so.
But then again,
my life revolves around fucking being
really into the next phone that comes
out.
Right?
What?
That new Siri.
There's a new intelligent assistant that
helps you out and they,
they,
they did a demo today,
which is a thing that you push and you
pretty much ask it any question you
want,
you can be like,
schedule me an appointment at 5:00
PM on Friday and then we'll go open up
your calendar and go,
do you want me to schedule this?
And just say yes and then we'll schedule
it.
Or you can go,
what's the weather like in New York?
And be like the weather,
the weather's this and it's like they
showed a bunch of examples and you can
see examples on apple.com
or any of the websites that can gadget
Gizmodo,
but it seems legit.
You can even say like call Joe,
like the android stuff too.
It's called Siri S.
I don't know if that's how it's spelled.
It's like an assist.
Yeah.
And it's pretty much the first step into
having no interaction with having to
touch your phone.
So this looks like maybe in five years
you're going to be texting by voice.
You're going to be calling,
you know,
you're not going to.
I would say this is a pretty good step.
I wouldn't say it's 100 percent there
right now.
Like I don't think you're,
you're still gonna.
Use your google voice,
the Google Google for you,
uh,
use your voice and you say,
you know,
10th Planet Jiu Jitsu.
You just use that as a surge boom.
And it instantly pulls up all.
I mean it's really accurate,
like the way it picks up the things that
you're saying,
it's super.
The thing that they showed today looks
even more amazing that.
And they also announced something that
we talked about earlier about an idea
I've had since I was a kid and now they
have it as a feature on the phone and
I'm like,
Shit,
should I,
it's they call it,
I forget what it's called,
but mine was called snail mail where it
was,
where,
I don't know if you remember,
you would write an email to this company
and the company would write it out and
hand form and then send it to somebody.
And I originally said I thought of the
idea because I wanted when my
grandmother was still alive,
I wanted to be able to email my
grandmother,
but then have somebody hand write it and
then send it to my grandmother.
Well now they just announced it on this
new iphone that it's a feature and I
forget what they call it,
but that's one of the new features.
Now it's like it's a real person hand
writes it.
I think it's either a handwriting.
I don't know if they do it by person.
I bet it's a printer that looks like
handwriting.
That's probably what they do.
But that's what the whole thing is.
It's two $99 per letter.
But that's kind of funny that,
that,
you know,
I should have fucking copyrighted that
alongside Chinese people.
That's all I'm thinking.
I'm thinking the shops sweatshops people
copying people's signatures.
Yeah.
That shit would be horrendous if you
found out that that was true.
I can't imagine that there's really a
business for that.
But yeah,
you did come up with that a long time.
A long time ago and the camera looks
awesome.
Now they're using a whole new lens
system,
which is making an eight megapixel and
hd is 10.
80 p I believe is what they should phone
the same phone.
You got to get a new phone,
you got to get a new phone for the
opera,
for ss,
a new phone.
It's got.
It's also got a dual processor now they
switched to.
They're a five chip,
so now it's supposed supposed to be
really fast.
So yeah,
it is a slight upgrade in some ways like
the screens nine,
any difference,
but there is a lot of stuff under the
hood.
Did they improve upon going from apps
back to your texting and sometimes
you're just looking at a white screen
for 20 seconds on your phone?
No,
no,
no.
Have you,
have you cracked your friend before?
I got a new phone.
I kept dropping on,
going from,
going from like twitter to my texting,
going back to the texting.
You just got to sit there and it takes
forever to cancel out the running
programs.
Do you know how to do that?
No.
Oh,
that's the problem.
Yeah.
You got to cancel out.
You're running programs,
it's like a computer,
it's really stupid,
it's a stupid
fucking design,
but if you press that home button,
the button on your screen,
you've got to press it twice and when it
does that,
a bunch of icons show up in the bottom
of the screen and you've got to manually
go through press one of them,
you hold it and it gives you the option
to delete it and then you go through all
of them,
deleting all of them and all you're
doing is shutting them off.
It's the stupidest thing ever.
Is one of apple's dumbest clumsy as
fuck.
Well,
I don't think you're gonna have to worry
about it too much anymore because this
process is two times faster now in the
graphics are seven times,
but still the fact that all these
applications stay open and running in
the background is only running the first
four.
They might show all of it running,
but the supposedly none of those other
programs are running except the first
four and then that even that,
the cameras,
the camera though,
33 percent more light.
Like why isn't it when you shut it off,
it's off because it's,
it's called multitasking so you can go
through it back and forth it and now
it's,
it's so it keeps a program running,
but only supposedly I thought only kept
the first for it might show all the
other programs,
but it's only actually using the first
Ford.
That's cool though because I have
had to tweet something and somebody sent
me a text and then a copy and the text
and then go right back to tweet and it's
wearing the same page.
That's exactly where it was.
Which wouldn't be if I had to close it
and open it.
Yeah,
that's huge.
That's huge.
Yeah,
that's pretty good.
The problem is going back like you're
gonna have to before you go to texting,
you gonna have to shut off everything
off.
That's probably even slower than just
hitting the Teks and waiting for like 20
seconds.
Right?
I mean they need to work on that because
that's a big fucking way.
What would she say?
What did you say?
What was that again?
So you got to turn off these programs so
that you don't get that delay going back
to the text.
No,
no,
no.
That's,
that's,
that's the process or a thing for the
most part.
I mean you can be running for intensive
programs.
Like if you had something crazy on like
ustream broadcaster,
I don't even know if that's an intense
program or a video game that might slow
it down a lot,
but this is two times faster now,
so you probably won't be having that
problem if that is the case of those
four programs.
Very interesting.
New phones supposedly has,
it has two antennas,
one antenna that sends one antenna that
receives instead of it both happening at
the same time.
So like it's supposed to double.
I might not be interpreting it exactly
correctly,
but it's supposed to be able to double
the downloads.
Yeah.
I don't know about the intensity.
I do know that it uses the verizon
antenna,
but I didn't see.
I'm looking for that right now.
What you're talking about.
That would make sense.
That'd be awesome.
If it had a,
an intended for both.
I read about it,
I don't know which one of the websites
or read about it,
but they said they had basically they
had duplicated four g speeds with a
three g device or what?
Some people consider four g speeds,
you know,
because there's some bunk ass four g
right?
If you get that verizon four g,
that's bad ass man.
I got up one of those.
A laptop cards,
man at the airport.
If you're in a place where it's four G,
it's.
It's amazing.
It's like Wifi.
It's like the best Wifi.
It's really good.
What I want to know though is is this
new version and it sounds like what
you're talking about,
this would make sense.
Is this new version for verizon?
Are you going to be able to talk and do
data at the same time?
Now the four lte network.
You can do that.
Okay.
But this isn't.
The Lte network is a four g anything
that's forward.
Right.
So this isn't for GE.
That was one of the big things that that
I think because the network's not ready
for iphone.
I think you're right.
You know,
one,
one thing that I think they need to
improve upon.
I think if they put like a,
like a headphone ear piece on each side
where you can like click it off and it's
wireless and you can put it on your,
you know what,
I'm going to click advanced headphones
with you because so many times I like,
I forget to bring my fucking headphones
on.
You know how many times I buy headphones
at the God damn airport if they just had
one to like clicked on,
like the corners you can pop it off and
there's.
And then you lose it and then your
iphone is everyone's gonna love lost
that like the first week or whatever,
but some or you know,
you know where you could pull it out and
then there's a wire even though,
because you know what I mean.
And then you pop it back in.
Are you talking about headphones for
listening to the things or talking on
the phone?
Headphones for listening to shit videos.
You're not talking about photography.
Well then it would work for that too.
Why not?
But I mean,
I never used a headphone and talk on the
phone.
I always hold the phone up to my.
Yeah,
but the more I'm reading about
radiation,
the more reading about cell phone
the more it really has to be thinking.
I'm really starting to think is there
really something to that?
Because the,
the what they accept,
like they say what the acceptable range
of radiation you're allowed to have this
whole time.
The wizards were right talking on
speakerphone outside is the way to go
there.
They're concerned about their brother,
their radiation product,
lizards.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
With black dudes who are really
aggressive,
who talk on the speakerphone on their
cell phone wizard wizards,
smart wizards,
because they're not getting radiation in
their head.
What is wrong?
That's what if those all those people
that use speakerphone.
I'm not saying,
but I'm talking about everybody on my ex
girlfriend does it to all those people
that use the speakerphone is that
they're probably thinking of it that
maybe maybe you know when you get to
this four g shit too,
now you've got some super potent flying
through the air.
What is all this shit flying through the
air man?
Where's that?
How's it
going?
I mean,
how,
how does that interact with ourselves?
The fact that all these different Wifi
signals and we could put on a like one
of those infrared goggles,
but you could see everything.
Like you can see the cell phone signal
and the information coming through if
you could just be everything.
You know what I mean?
We're in a sea of like frequencies.
Who the fuck knows what that actually
looks like.
Someone knows how it works.
Like who the fuck figured out how that
cell phone works.
You know what I mean?
Now we're sending video through the air.
Someone figured out that there was like
some tracks that we can put information
on an Ra and Jesus is magic and when
you're in a place that has nothing,
there's a certain sound to the silence
like of the mountains.
There's a certain sound where it's
almost like all us isn't
really a sound,
but it just a very low frequency that we
can't tune into.
Imagine if it just affects your everyday
consciousness.
You just don't realize it.
If your everyday consciousness just
slightly pressured by all of these
vibrations that are around you all the
time,
all these cell phones,
signals and fucking Wifi signals and
satellite signals and radio signals and
fuck.
Imagine if that is really fucking with
our personalities.
Imagine if you'd be a different person
or at least add.
Feel different.
Yeah.
Add.
Who knows,
who knows how many different things.
Who knows?
Oh,
I wonder what all this shit is doing to
us.
It's only been around for a few.
You know,
how long it started with TV signals and
radio signals or radio furs than TV and
then.
And it mean,
but within the last couple decades,
the amount of infiltration in our lives
by frequencies and
walkie talkies.
Man,
how the fuck did they forgot walkie
talkies?
You know what I mean?
That's amazing.
A walkie talkies fucking crazy.
Well,
they use to be able to send things and
they weren't encoded either.
You'd have to have to manually encode
their information because they didn't
want people that were.
The enemy was tuning into their shit
too.
So everybody had to talk in code.
Wrap your head around that like not only
is there no email but you when you,
when you send some signal out,
anybody can get that signal.
So you're in the bottom of the summary.
De de,
De,
de,
de.
The Japanese are listening.
They hear your fucking signal.
You can't,
you can't just send it just to you.
It's crazy like that.
As technology just snowballs.
It's the more access we have that
instant information,
infinite information.
The more,
the more free we feel,
the more we can get.
Keep track of,
you know,
like the government get they get when
you want to.
CSI Shit.
Every move you make they could just
break it down from your cell phones.
They know what cell phone tower you hit,
they know exactly where you were from,
the cell phone towers.
They can go back and all the deleted
messages that you all shit you deleted.
They can go back and retrieve them like
there's some kind of imprint of this
shit somewhere like,
holy fuck.
We think like,
oh,
we're more powerful,
more connected.
We're more under control that more than
anything.
You know,
every little move we make,
they,
they know exactly.
If they needed a pinpoint somebody how
easy it is to fucking find somebody.
You're going to live off the grid.
How long is that going to last?
You better go to the Amazon jungle.
You know what I mean?
That's the only place you're going to
survive.
They'll find you.
Well,
it certainly,
it's the connections.
Much more immersive than it's ever been
before.
There's never been any at any point in
time where people are so easy to get in
contact with other people.
Yeah,
I know.
Did you,
did you hear about that guy that are
around your neighborhood?
Uh,
he flew off the,
a side of a cliff and there wasn't cell
phone service there,
so we couldn't use a cell phone and he,
him and he got in a car accident with
another person or something like that.
And then both of their cars are down
there.
The other guy died.
And so his body was like everywhere and
broke,
like every single bone in his body was
still alive and he tried to crawl out,
but he couldn't move because everything
was broken.
And for 10 days he sat down there with
his dead guy living off of grass and
bugs and creek.
There was like a little creek water,
I guess he would,
he would drink,
but for 10 days he lived there.
And then one day his love his son or
something like that was going down the
road,
like looking,
there's still kind of looking for them
and stuff.
And he hurt his dad's help yell for
help.
And they found his body,
but he didn't have cell phone service
there.
And if he would have had been able to.
He said he,
the whole time was just searching his
cell phone,
his cell phone died and stuff.
But can you imagine 10 days on the
bottom of a creek and there's not cell
phone service and it was just all fucked
up.
So we couldn't walk out of there.
Yeah.
But he's alive now and he's,
uh,
he's doing,
he's recovering and everything.
But imagine being 10 days at Brown and
dead person too.
It's also just think of
a how vulnerable your body is.
And if you body breaks,
you're just stuck.
You can't move,
you know?
I don't think most of us don't wrap our
heads around that.
Your body breaks,
then you can't move.
And then being out in the woods so you
get to things that scare the fuck out of
people being alone out in the uncharted
wilderness.
Hearing cars drive
you above you.
Everyday it's on be is just a side of
the roads,
you know,
in some area that's,
people drive by every day.
That might as well be uncharted
wilderness.
Nobody goes.
Yeah,
they said,
they said that people fly off of those
clips all the time and never get found
because it's just like,
who goes down there?
No one goes down there.
Nobody goes looking to find cars down
there all the time.
Yeah,
that's just,
that's a scary thing,
man.
That's the cliff driving ever do the
Pacific coast,
Pacific coast all the way up to
Monterrey and all the way that.
Ooh,
that's scary.
It's beautiful.
Fuck the first time I did it,
I was 28 years old and I never took that
drug.
I was like,
I live in California,
and I never knew that.
It was one of the most beautiful states
ever.
Incredible scenery.
It's so cliffs in the rocks.
It's so hard to even wrap your head
around.
It's magnificent.
I kept pulling over the girl I was with.
We took a little trip for a couple of
days.
He kept.
I kept pulling over just videotaping.
I couldn't believe this was California.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
I've never been up to northern
California before on the east coast.
There's a lot of parts of that fucking
drive.
Were you just counting on the other
asshole on the other side to just be
cool?
He'd been together.
Stay in your lane.
Don't be texting.
Isn't it crazy how they put a big halt
to that satellite phone?
Remember it was big like six,
seven years ago.
It was like the future,
like,
and the commercial was dude was in the
wilderness on a mountain and he was
making a call like,
this is the best shit,
and then boom,
they just shut it all down.
No,
they have satellite phones.
They still don't.
How come it didn't blow up?
Oh No,
it's not that efficient.
Yeah.
It wasn't a world phone now,
didn't they have,
didn't they?
Didn't,
they shut down the satellite phones
because of the whole terrorism thing.
I think they briefly shut them down
around that time period,
but I don't think.
I think they still have,
um,
somebody had a satellite phone the other
day or a.
Oh wait,
that was last.
Nevermind.
I think they,
I think they use them on a sort of fear
factor.
If we used to use them all the time.
We used to have to use satellite phones.
There were certain sets that we'd
beyond,
but there was nothing.
There was nothing.
You didn't think of it.
That would be huge.
I thought I thought they got shut down a
expensive.
I don't think the sound quality's that
good either.
I think that's a big delay is a little
more,
I shouldn't say a big delay.
It's fucking amazing.
It goes up to the sky and then back down
and that's what reporters should have
phones that like regular phones with
like fucking nine g you got the
satellite.
If you need it,
you just click on the little thing just
in case like these stories flag off
cliffs and shed get lost in the woods.
You know how many movies have like
someone getting chased and their cell
phone signal,
so now it's a good idea because now
there's the t the chips are slowly
shrinking to the point where you could
get all that in in one phone,
but if you ever look at the satellite
phones,
there's a reason where there's big giant
bricks.
I mean the receiver has to be completely
different than a little tiny one.
Internal.
I'm going to be the new pimp floss.
Then it's also nowadays cars.
Cars have it built in like my car has a
feature in it that you can turn on that
if I can in a car accident and
automatically texts my gps and sends it
and calls nine.
One one.
Yeah,
for does that right?
Saying somebody told me this and I don't
know if it's true.
So twitter people fucking informed me.
Tell me if this is true.
Somebody said that the dude bought a
corvette and it had that.
What is the thing?
The onstar system on star guy was going
down the highway going 148 miles an hour
or something crazy like that.
Onstar shut off his car now called the
police.
Now that's not true.
You sure that's not true?
One hundred percent and that's not true.
No way that the onstar even is
monitoring how fast or driving or do
anything.
I thought it saves information.
If you're in a wreck they can find out
that your data might save it.
But there's so many cars.
I have onstar and the fact that they
actually have people sitting there will
go in.
All right,
he's going 120 over here.
You know there's no one monitoring that.
That'd be unless you get in a car
accident,
maybe it's the program itself.
Maybe onstar itself when it recognizes
that you hit a certain amount of miles
per hour,
they shut your car off if you don't
think that's possible.
I know it's possible that they could
shut it off if someone's driving it.
Right?
Can't they shut her off?
What's that called,
Jack Something Jack?
I think I've done that.
The crux of them,
they'd done that to people before.
Shut their cars off while they're
driving.
It seems like they have.
I don't know,
maybe I'm making this up.
It seems like a car.
That was that one reality show where
people steal cars.
That's what I'm thinking.
Like you know the way things are going
to kill switches,
it looks like,
you know,
I don't know.
I could be wrong,
but it looks like in the future,
like it's just going to be mandatory.
It's going to be a law that the CHP or
the police department or whatever the
fuck they call the forest back then has
gps on your shit and like the DMV and
they just monitor every mile you drive,
so anytime you fuck up they just send
you tickets.
They go,
we have your gps fingerprint.
You manage your gps record.
Can you imagine that shit?
Fuck them cameras.
Like in England they got cameras,
they got better.
You know that.
They take pictures,
but they're not going to need that.
The DMV just gonna Monitor your driving
every day you'll have a sheet.
Oh,
he broke.
You know there's a ticket.
Here's a ticket.
Boom.
No more hiding.
No more speeding.
You have to go to a track if you want to
go fast than spots like that and we
can't.
Sometimes speed limits.
Ridiculous.
For the most part,
it's speed limits.
Probably pretty smart to have a,
a decent number set and a lot of places,
but there's a lot of places where it's
silly like the highway,
the fuck out of here.
Will you see 55 miles an hour,
get the fuck outta here.
That's stupid.
That's a stupid way to move.
Fifty five miles an hour.
How?
What kind of car do you have?
Maybe if you're a fucking old jalopy
back when they instituted that speed
limit and it made sense because if
you're going more than 55 miles an hour
and old fucking Chevy Nova,
one of those six cylinder shit boxes,
you know those break suck dude.
You know if you're actually going fast
and one of those cars.
I mean they're awesome cars when people
rebuild them,
don't get me wrong,
but I mean in compared to today's
technology,
the technology,
those cars,
they couldn't handle well and they
couldn't break well.
I haven't had that much where you're
breaking the car,
slamming on the brakes.
That's scary.
That's a common.
That's why.
That's why we need to move to Texas.
I heard that they now have their voting
to get the speed limit.
Moved to 90 I think is what they were
saying.
Maybe it was 80,
but there's a lot of parts of Texas I
fucking love.
Oh,
speaking of which,
I'm in Texas this weekend.
Powerful Verizon Center this Friday
night,
and you haven't been to Houston so long,
you still use the own Houston every time
you went into town you would sell me.
No,
I know,
but you would sell out every single
show.
That was the biggest market and then
they closed the comedy club that we love
to go to.
I went to the second member of boy in
Houston,
I'd want to say his name,
but I remember a boy in Houston.
He came out on the road with us.
Um,
red devil when he was in red.
Classic.
He never came on the road with us.
We were always going on the subject and
no one's going to know what the fuck I'm
talking about.
Yeah,
that's why you explain it.
There's a mic.
We got three hours but you otherwise.
But this place just about Toyota Toyota
Center or Verizon Center.
I can't remember where the standup is.
Yeah,
yeah.
You were on a radio station there the
other day and he said that radio was
pretty ridiculous.
Like,
yeah,
they were nice.
They were cool.
They played that a supernanny song.
They play your song all the time.
Yeah.
He was just quoting a bet that I did.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
I don't even know that bit,
but now after I got off the phone with
them I was like,
damn,
I think he was right.
I think that is a line in one of my old
bits that I forgot because he was
talking something about toe ring.
I'm like,
have a jug about a toe ring.
And he goes,
you could do.
And I'm like,
are you high or drunk?
I don't remember a joke about a tour.
I think it's like a line in one of my
old old jokes,
you know,
if you play like I've played back my
shit from like 1999 and it almost as if
like it's someone else's
material.
I don't even know it anymore,
you know?
I mean I remember it.
Yeah.
That was one of my jokes,
but I don't even know them anymore.
So if like somebody quotes like a little
piece of it,
I might not even know what the fuck
they're talking about.
It seems so weird for something that for
years you're so intimately connected to,
but when you have material and then you
abandoned it and start on some new
material,
you fucking forget every did when you
started smoking weed was at 30 to 30,
31 and 30.
He went from like pure Dick Jokes and
relationship jokes and chick jokes and
cock blocking jokes and then right into
your pyramid bit.
You started smoking.
When did the paramed bid people?
Dumb people.
People out.
Fucking smart people and a staggering
pace.
Why doritos are so funny and wacky.
Yeah,
it changed my comedy for sure.
We'd made a complete turn in my comedy.
You know,
it's like I just Kinda,
I learned to see things differently.
You know,
you got some good classics before we'd
done for sure fucking time.
Nicole Smith the tiger.
But how many times have I been on the
road and I just wanted to hear the
title.
I've heard a thousand times.
I'm always like,
you know,
like shut up motherfucker.
That was one of those bits.
It was so hard to let go.
I love tiger with the ultimate bit.
Now I'll never get tired of that one.
I had to let it go though.
Whenever you have a,
you know,
you got new material.
You can't keep remembering the old
material.
I really don't remember exactly how can
I get a tiger sound just to give me a
little fucking so real roar.
That was on the fair.
I can't remember.
You had a better job too.
What was that?
Remember when the bear attack,
the karate trainer.
There was a.
That was the guy who was a trainer and
he's dressed in a karate outfit and he
had a lady come onstage to them and the
lady sat in the chair and the bear
turned and looked at the lady and just
started fucking her up.
Just started fucking her up,
but it was just like the bear just woke
up and realized I'm a fucking bear and
then it just starts wailing like out of
nowhere to dude that a karate outfit.
He was trying to protect the guy on
youtube.
That was way before you go debt.
No,
no,
no.
That's the story.
Actual store video.
Yeah.
I bet that.
I bet somebody put it online down.
I would like to see because I heard so
much youtube.
I heard that joke so much is crazy.
Never actually seen the real footage of
air.
Just turns this lady and starts fucking
her up for no reason.
She sat down.
That's the weirdest thing about animals,
man.
Sometimes you don't realize,
but like,
like trained animals,
like sometimes they're just tweaked like
they're tired of this.
They don't want to do this anymore.
This is stupid.
I don't want to be led around why you
fucking with me?
What's going on here?
And then it looks normal because they do
it every day and they don't know how to
communicate,
but they're a little tweet and so they
sit down and the fucking lady sits right
now next to him and he just decided to
fuck her up out of nowhere.
And it looks like it's out of nowhere,
but it's been built up all day because
you got this fucking stupid bear doing
somersaults.
You know,
you've got this bear,
you know,
instead of killing deers in eat and
berries and shit,
this bears running around on chairs.
You know,
playing musical chairs are porter,
what the fuck are you doing,
man?
That's a.
that's a big,
crazy unpredictable animal.
There's a video of a dude who is
training a bear and he was training
with,
I believe it was his brother or his
cousin,
someone who is a close family member,
I think it was his brother,
and the bear just turns on the guy for
no reason and rips his throat out.
It happens in 30,
not even 30 seconds,
10 seconds,
maybe a maximum for no reason.
They're all had this bear in this room.
The bed just turns on.
The guy goes right at his neck and rips
it out and the guy bled out and died
right there.
Isn't it crazy that some when when these
trained animals,
a lot of them,
when they attack,
they don't kill him because it's like
they give them another chance.
They might like the killer whale.
Didn't they get that killer whale like
band this bear?
They didn't kill this bear.
It's a why.
It just seems like it's costs more money
to retrain another bear than to pay the
insurance policy on.
You know what I mean?
It's gotTa.
It's gotta be what it is.
I don't get it.
You know,
I don't understand how anybody can
convince anybody that had a bear that
wants,
that has already killed a person who
offered no threat whatsoever.
That thing,
if a person did that,
you would kill them.
You give them the death penalty in a
right society.
If you saw someone run up to someone for
no reason to rip your throat out,
you would kill them.
Why the fuck would you give a bear more
rights and you'd give up maybe not
killed a bear because I don't blame the
bear for doing that.
But like,
you know,
throwing,
uh,
it,
lock them away somewhere or something.
You know what I mean?
Don't continue to use them as a buffoon.
I was going to attack again.
Lock in a bear away would be cruel and
unusual punishment.
I'd say just put one in his fucking dome
and at them in the wild.
Fuck it.
Give him a chance.
He,
they,
that you take and you train and you do
all that within it turns and eats your
brother's fucking throat in front of
you.
You're supposed to kill that thing like
crazy wild thing that you thought you
were in control of.
The fuck is wrong.
If it was up to me,
I would take them up to the mountains
and give him a check and now you
probably had another lose.
No survival skills or anything good
luck,
but at least you give them a chance.
Who knows?
Maybe they could make it maybe,
but they're probably not.
That's terrible idea because then you
set an animal loose that's used to being
in contact with human beings and you set
them out in the woods and he will find
human beings and it poses a direct
threat to those people.
They're really dangerous.
Once you have habitualized a bear to
people,
they have to lock them up.
They have to put them in cages in zoos.
The zoos we went to in Colorado,
I learned that there because they had
these bears and these bears had gotten
their big ass grizzlies man,
big ass brown bears and they um,
they were getting into people's garbage
and once they find this is where the
people keep the food,
it's a source of food.
They won't go away.
You can't scare them,
you know,
at a certain point in time,
they just get used to you and they just
fuck you.
So unless
you shoot them,
they have to have someone come and
capture them and they leave and they
take them away.
You can't just let that bear,
I lose lose.
You'd find people in that.
One time I did,
I did five grams of mushrooms and I went
to the zoo.
I thought it'd be a great idea and by
the time I got to the zoo,
that's when it started kicking in.
I blew up at the zoo.
That freaked me out.
I'm like,
fuck,
these animals are fucking sad as hell.
They're all captured there in prison.
I ran out of that.
Got Em zoo.
That's how those people are jumping into
the polar bear bear cages.
I bet they're always on shrooms or bear.
The polar bear was there's like,
it's like a little fucking old school
little auditorium theater thing that you
got for this polar bear and there's a
door and I backstage and it just kept
walking through that door and then walk
away from the door like a couple of
yards and walking back waiting for
someone to open that door and it was
just pacing back and forth nonstop.
This polar bear like,
wow,
I freaked the fuck out.
I was just hoping
some asshole comes and opens the door
and he can bite them and drag them and
finish him off.
You know?
That's what they're doing.
They're just dying for someone to go in
there so they could track them.
Great.
That's why they you.
You ever seen the video?
The lady getting her leg broken.
He.
He bites down on her leg and he's
pulling her leg through the fucking
bars.
It's polar bears are motherfuckers,
man.
They're real motherfuckers and you don't
ever really tame those things.
Those things are.
They're the craziest bears of all
because they're the straight carnivore
bears.
All the other bears eat fruits and
berries.
It's no fucking fruits and berries with
the polar bear lives.
Just Coca Cola,
just just seals and people and whatever
the fuck else he can eat whales,
the whales,
they find a hole where a whale got stuck
under a giant sheet of ice.
The whale can't go anywhere,
so every time the whale comes up to get
some air,
boom,
polar bear.
Jackson takes a bite out of them.
So these whales,
like you see him and after a while
they're the top of their back.
It's just destroyed.
Whoa.
From polar bears,
just biting them over and over and over
and over again,
and then eventually they kill it.
So small whale or something like that.
It gets stuck in their pilot whale.
They just slowly bite them to death.
That's incredible.
Did you see the video that Mary Archie
Band playing a song music for?
I think it was a.
What are the snow lions or something
like that?
Snow leopards snow.
There's big things as big blobby.
They almost like hippos.
Like what's the ones that are all seals
and sea lions?
Maybe that,
but it was so cool.
They were the.
It looked like it was having a fun time
watching,
like it was going back and forth.
It's explaining what you saw.
Okay.
Here I'll show it to you.
It's a,
I think it's on Google.
Mariachi band,
Mariachi band.
A Sea lion.
So they're playing the music and the sea
lions dancing along with it.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah,
it's,
it's amazing.
And like,
uh,
when the trumpet players
would like to do in,
like tilt his head up and down and then
would head up and down and it just
looked like it was having the time of
its life.
It's one of the coolest videos I've
seen.
I'll find it right now for the wonder.
I always wonder like what music,
what kind of an effect music would have
on animals because you know,
in the animal kingdom it's actually a
Beluga whale occasion at all.
But why wouldn't music impact them the
same way it impacts us?
Why wouldn't it be exciting and
interesting to them?
It's actually a Beluga whale and if you
look at it,
it's a on [inaudible] dot com.
It's Mariachi Band serenades,
that Beluga whale and it's just going
back and forth.
Well that makes sense as well as a way
smarter than you realize.
And they started.
It is.
I didn't,
I couldn't remember what it was.
They start playing more and more and it
starts really like nodding its head and
you know,
you know what's interesting about this,
that we're,
we're amazed that this is intelligent
because if that was a person and if you
like,
look at my boy,
I took my boy to see the Mariachi band.
Look how my boy nods.
Nods.
He acknowledges them,
they acknowledged him back.
My Boys.
Brilliant.
So far is not really doing anything but
what I'm saying to get better.
The only reason why this is interesting
is because it's not a human.
If it's a person that's a drooling idiot
listening to bad music.
Okay,
wait,
let me see.
I'm like,
get to the good part
right now.
He's just going,
what the fuck are those hats?
Or before they hear the nodding with
the,
with the music and stuff like that.
I mean it's kind of cute.
I'm not saying it's like a breakthrough
in science or anything.
It's just a cool video to watch.
I think you were saying it was a
breakthrough in science.
I think that's.
I think that dolphins like you guys got
fish or something.
What's going on?
Yeah.
I think he's bored as fuck.
Trapped in snack time.
What's going on?
People are filming him.
I chose assholes.
Make weird music.
Yeah.
Poor thing.
See in jail.
Things in jail.
No wonder he fucking stare at you when
it comes to the glass.
Yeah.
Wow.
Amazing.
I'm going to let me go.
Did a Freedom Day.
That's the thing that we have to be the
most concerned about with aliens,
man,
because of the disrespect that we have
for everything even remotely dumber than
us.
Even whales,
killer whales,
orcas,
dolphins.
Those are thought to be really
intelligent animals.
We don't totally understand their,
their languages.
We know that they have,
like some of them have dialects and
she'll like.
There's.
They're really complicated.
Both killer whales and dolphins.
They're like cousins of each other,
but we don't understand what they say,
so we were like,
mm,
I don't give a fuck getting the tank,
and we just forced them into prison for
us.
We and we all go watch them perform and
fly through the air and splash as
everybody claps.
We're watching slaves were watching
babies that stolen from
their mothers,
from intelligent animals that miss them
and we don't care because we don't
understand what they're saying.
La,
la,
la.
I'm not listening.
What's the latest on deciphering the
Dolphin or whale language?
I mean because we're trying to teach
them our words like jump.
That's the tricky thing.
They,
you know,
they can recognize many,
many human words,
but we can't understand a single thing
they're saying there's got to be someone
on the case trying to decipher that shit
will be.
Leary was not timothy leary rather.
I'm the guy who created,
created the isolation tank.
Goddammit.
Is there some new shit with the
isolation tank where they're sending
radio waves through it now?
Is there.
So is that the latest thing or is that
still you laying in water at a certain
temperature or is there some
electromagnetic shit going on now?
Will they do have a John Lilly do?
They do have some where they,
um,
they play sound float lab has got some
crazy new video screen that they're
developing where it's,
it sits right in front of you and has
the lowest possible emission of light so
that you don't see the machinery at all.
All you see is the image that's being
played on this DVD because you're in
total complete darkness in there.
And the speakers are these,
these sort of underwater waterproof
speakers that are beside each year.
They're fixed,
fixed in place.
So you set yourself in between these two
speakers and then this video plays.
And in the sensory deprivation
environment,
when you're in there,
you are weightless and body list and you
don't feel shit.
You feel like you're flying through the
universe and then all of a sudden this
image appears right before you.
And the sound of it.
It sounds pretty dope.
I haven't tried it though.
Well,
I like going in there and just,
I don't want to,
I don't,
I'm not looking to add anything.
I'm looking to figure out what the fuck
is out there.
You know,
when I go into the tank,
I'm never thinking,
oh,
how dope would this if I played a whole
lot of love while while I was in there.
Let's get.
I'm gonna get high as fuck.
And then um,
uh,
you know,
it would be cool to do,
but to me,
my time in there,
what I,
what I'm,
what I gravitate towards is doing it
with nothing.
I'm,
I like,
I like silence and I like seeing where
the fuck my crazy imagination takes me
or where,
where,
where the muse takes me,
wherever,
whatever happens.
Now imagine recording of it.
Did you see that thing where scientists
can now record,
and this is scary.
This is a thing they have on Gizmodo,
but where they had somebody watch a
bunch of videos and,
and then they recorded the brain's
activity and they,
they show on this video.
It compares what they actually saw and
what the brain sees the cats.
I've seen that they've recorded,
so can you,
can you imagine now that that like 10
years from now they're going to be able
to like record everything that you see.
You're not going to be able to lie
anymore.
You're not going to be able to do
anything where it's headed.
Ultimately they'll.
There'll be waterproof iphones that you
could swim with and that translates what
you're saying to dolphin language so
that you can just communicate with
dolphins.
I mean,
it's getting crazy,
right?
I don't think they're ever going to be
able to figure out the dolphin thing.
They're so far off.
Dolphin APP never say never.
Humans,
humans communicating with humans is
going to get real weird man.
You know,
can figure that dolphin
boy,
they're not close.
They're not even close.
I don't know what the fuck the dolphins
are saying.
You don't know what.
They can't talk the dolphins.
They can't send out a message to the
dolphins.
Hello Dolphin world.
We are friendly,
but what if they created some instrument
where they decide for some sounds and
they go,
let's see what this sound.
You know,
dissect the sounds,
edit them,
put them together and then plan for the
Dolphin and maybe the dog because that
doesn't make any sense,
but that was kind of weird,
right?
They may slowly put words together like,
oh,
we got eat.
We got the one for.
Even if they had like rewords down,
you know what I mean?
Then they go,
I mean maybe we should research where
the,
the Dolphin communication world is that
right now I want to know.
I want to.
I know that a mentoree John Lilly,
that was one of the reasons why I
created a what,
what would he rather uses that he used
the tank for?
He used to put a tank on isolation tank
right next to the dolphin tank and he
would drop acid and get into the tank
and communicate with the dolphins and
he's like this pioneer and interspecies
communication and because of that,
but what does that mean?
I mean,
how much have they figured out?
As far as I know,
they have figured out very little and I
think we're the whole dolphin language
is a mystery,
but we do know that they have dialects.
We know that different dolphin pods have
like a,
like if they're from a different place,
I'll have like a different twice.
If they know that they can tell that the
different dialect,
they can decipher one little sound like
maybe,
maybe something in the.
I think it's a matter of context.
If you lived in a world,
see we have.
We live in a material world as as the
ocean oceans and material world,
but it's in a material world where
you're not stuck to the ground.
You're going all over the place,
your world,
your you've are flying through your
world.
Everyone is flying through the world of
the ocean.
It's a completely different experience
to not be able to alter your
environment,
to develop some sort of intelligence to
the level that dolphins have and,
and orcas have to the point where
they'll help people.
They recognize when people are in
trouble and they help them.
Like killer whales will like help people
get to boats.
I want to see,
I want to read something on that twitter
people I want some like documented
that's happened where and exactly what's
happened.
Like how the hell bent more than one
instance of guys capsizing boats and
Orcas helping them help them back into
the boat to amazing how they don't
attack humans.
They don't.
People swim with like a pod of Orca
where they go,
they.
Yeah.
I don't know if they will let you do
that man.
I don't know if they have children.
That doesn't seem to be a good idea.
I know you know people have been bitten
or nudged or bumped and shit before,
but I think they're pretty fucking easy
going with people.
There was something I read online a long
time ago,
but it turned out to be horseshit.
It was that people used to get killed by
killer whales all the time until a
fighter pilots in world war two started
using orchids for target practice,
you know,
and they don't do shit like that.
I mean they would use like killer whales
or sharks or something like that for
target practice when they're dry fly.
And I heard that,
and then all of a sudden killer whales
stop killing people.
They had like some kind of committee and
says,
you know
what,
it's a.
it's a good idea for the,
for the existence of our species.
Don't fuck with these humans.
These pink monkeys with their bang
sticks.
You don't want to be fucking with them.
They can do some damage.
They can get out in our world that we
can't go to their world.
So they just get in big wooden boats and
go out to our world.
And as long as the boat's big enough,
you get in one of those giant ocean
liner type things.
What the fuck's killer?
We're going to do that.
You can just go around and jacking up
left and right.
It was terrible environment they live
in.
It's crazy how the dolphins and the
Caribbean or in the Gulf of Mexico or
the Bahamas,
not area,
the ones they study,
they did a documentary on it and it's a
trip.
How they capture females,
they capture them either to males.
It's either two males and they captured
one female at a time for like a month
and then they jacker or it's a big group
of males like 15 to 20 and they capture
a bunch of females and make sure they
don't swim off the pot and they're just
taking turns on them and it's funny is
the girls want to leave.
They want to take off.
They don't want to be captured,
not because they don't want to have sex,
but because they want to have sex with
as many males in that region,
so when they have their baby,
if they.
It's like a.
A woman female dolphin had sex with a
hundred male dolphins when she gives
birth and she asked to watch over her
child for the first three or four years.
If she runs into and she's by herself
with her child,
they're just swimming around when they
run into males.
If those males have had sex with her,
they'll leave her alone.
If those males that run into a didn't
have sex with her,
they will kill that baby and then
capture her and bring her into their
little Harem.
They will kill the baby boy,
that's not that,
but if they run into them,
so that's so the female has to have as
much sex as possible.
She's down with the sexual,
but she wants to leave and go find some
more guys before the baby hatches.
It's crazy,
right?
It's insane.
But it's the same because people think
of dolphins as being these fun,
loving,
whimsical fairies of the sea.
There are cousins that are fairies in
the sea.
They're all loving because you know
they're,
they're cool as fuck to us.
You know,
if you ever in a boat and you're
swimming by some dolphins are robots,
dolphins,
they'll jump up and play with you.
You know,
it's interesting,
but in the dolphin world,
when things get hard,
shit gets crazy.
Yeah,
I know when it's a big group of males
and they run into a couple of dudes who
have captured a check,
they will jack those dudes.
And steel is steel there,
girl like that.
This is our girl now.
Crazy evil bitches.
So dolphins are just like people a lot
of ways.
Everything intelligent.
This is what I was saying,
things in that region.
Not all dolphins,
I don't think all Davao,
they all have their own special,
but every mating rituals.
Well,
you know,
killer whales killed dolphins all the
time and not only that,
killer whales got their name not from
being killers,
but from killing whales.
That's what they,
that's where they came up with the name
of killer whales,
killer whales.
Fuck whales up.
There's some horrible videos of killer
whales
biting a whale's face off like a blue
whale or something.
Yeah,
like a big,
big ass whale and just jack and his face
and the wheels trying to swim away and
they're just fucking this whale up and
it's like,
it makes you really like,
think like,
wow.
Like what we think of is like some cute
thing that does tricks at the zoo.
That's a murdering monster that lives in
the ocean and they're smart and think
about what we do to them.
It's just we don't give a fuck.
We can't understand them.
So we just put them in the cage.
Get in there,
bitch.
I don't know what you're saying.
They're going,
my mother.
My father,
Ms Dot my family.
What are you doing?
Um,
I was born to swim the open seas.
All we hear is what if they have the
answers to the universe?
They know all the answers where we came
from,
they know everything they,
they've been trying to tell us,
but they just can't communicate when we
don't listen,
logged in.
They're just,
they know all about the Galactic
Federation.
They know what's going on and go,
dude,
a comment's going to jack you in three
years.
You better get on.
Father was like ones and Zeros.
It was all like modem sounds and we just
haven't been able to.
People are so.
Yeah,
right?
Yeah.
People are so fucking toxic.
We don't just ruin our world.
We ruined the ocean world too.
We pollute the ocean world and we eat
everything that's in there.
I mean if you think about the two worlds
that exist right next to each other.
Okay.
There's the world of land and in this
world of the ocean,
in the world of land,
you don't get to fly,
but unless you get in tubes and metal
and shit like that,
but you do get to manipulate matter.
You get to use your thumbs and make
things and create things.
The world of the ocean,
you can fly all over the place,
but you can't manipulate matter.
Well,
what happens?
the ones who get manipulate matter to
figure out a way to make tools and make
a vehicles to fly over to where you live
and fuck you up.
You know what we're doing,
we don't think about we are at war with
the ocean and we're.
We're in a,
in an ocean of oxygen.
We're just like crabs.
We just can't sweat around.
We're just the bottom feeders.
You know?
There's a lot of motherfuckers flying
around birds and shit.
It's an ocean of oxygen that we're
walking around and yeah,
but in the,
in the ocean,
yeah,
that's very true.
Right?
And we are the,
the crabs of the outer world,
right?
Because there are animals.
It's not like the water.
There's water and then there's oxygen.
It's just crap.
That's a good point because cramps can't
fucking swim.
They just stuck there.
They're down there to clean things.
Hate those fuckers.
Cleanup.
Stupid.
Yeah.
That's the when sharks run around Jack
and people and a foot falls to the
ground.
So the crabs,
crabs go at it.
That football?
Yeah,
and crabs.
Always known for the term crabs in a
bucket.
Whenever you.
You're around people and they're fucking
holding each other down.
Do people still get cramps but people
still getting cramps?
That's not still around 70,
79.
I don't know.
I heard of crabs in years,
but I'm sure it's out there.
You just gotTa look for it.
And then high school they used to say
that,
dude,
I got the crabs.
Crabs like the wrong dirty,
dirty,
dirty bitch.
Yeah,
hippies.
Hippies really can.
You have crabs if you shaved your pussy
and they've really hard.
It's harder.
That's probably why girls started
shaving their policies.
It was always the form checks,
right?
They gotta do we gotTa fucking shave.
So it's like a chemo thing,
you know,
at first.
But then it became cool.
Well,
you know,
there was like a,
a run of people who thought it was
offensive to ask women to shave their
pussies.
There was like a big,
you know,
back in the day when women had bushes.
I remember like the debates when it was
like porn was starting to alter people's
perceptions of what sexual organs could,
should look like.
And I've read some,
some thing about this where they were
discussing how,
you know,
women are upset that their husbands want
them to shave their pussies and make it
look like the porn girls.
You know,
that it's offensive and it's
objectifying.
But now everyone shapes.
The only thing about a hairy pussy is,
is I used to like,
I used to prefer hairy pussies in my
early twenties,
believe it or not because girls had
shaved sometimes if they didn't shave
and they have that,
that,
that roughness.
It's like you're fucking sandpaper
sometimes,
but if they're,
if they have like a bush,
it's all mushy gushy and machines soft.
Right.
I wonder why it's there specifically.
Do you think that's what it is?
It's an eyelash there because people
usually fuck missionary and it's to
protect that area.
No,
it's a hair is a good way to send off
your sense.
Does the hair and then wind blows on the
hair and then.
Oh,
so that's why it's around your asshole.
Yep.
So you can send out the asshole Sunday
up.
Apparently farts are aphrodisiacs or
when we were cavemen whites.
Yep.
Because it was awesome that this guy got
some food.
I like foreign.
That motherfucker just ate an elk.
A Saber.
Tooth tiger.
God dammit.
Figured out.
I take that brontosaurus down.
Now he's in my face.
Have you heard of Americans?
Americans are.
Yeah.
It's like a fake pube yeah.
There's a fig pubic hair you can buy
like a lot of girls like to do the laser
now down there and get all their pubic
hair taken away and then they buy
Merkins if they ever want pubic hair
once.
That's crazy.
They were like a pubic hair.
Tupac.
Tupac fashion ones that they use.
Who would,
who?
Japanese.
That's my gosh.
I have no idea.
Oh,
it is.
No,
no,
that's what I would say that people at
burning man,
they like the craziest shit.
You know Japanese can't.
You're not allowed to show pubic hair.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
Something.
They don't shave their fucking pews.
How weird is that?
I think you're not need the Japanese if
you're listening out there,
you guys shaved that thing,
man.
God Damn it.
No one likes that.
But he would sell so much more porn.
Relatively unherald compared to a lot of
girls.
Very Japanese are hairless,
but fuck,
all of a sudden it all,
you know what it all takes place in the
pussy.
They don't have enough hair to
go around for the legs and the arms and
shit.
It all.
Dude.
You haven't seen Japanese porn?
I have seen a very little shit.
Do you think the Japanese girls are
hypersexual?
Can I,
you know,
I think redheads are in.
Here's,
here's why I've been doing some
research.
Redheads have thinner skin.
They also are very,
a lot more sensitive to a lot of things
like when you get put out as a ginger,
like you have to have more a shit to put
you out.
Like they,
they actually have different.
When you go outside you need sunscreen,
what you're saying would they have
thinner skin and they have a few things
that are different than normal people
and so they're like overly sensitive,
like they bruise easier.
They the sunlight shit,
but there's also like when they're,
when they're in hospitals they have to
use more medicine to knock them out too.
And it's,
it's weird.
I don't know a bunch of it like,
so you think there are separate species?
I think they,
they're,
they're the closest to being different
than,
than like Asian people.
Really.
You think that the Asian Asian people
don't have thinner skin than us?
They don't have.
They're not more sensitive to skin and
light.
They also like,
there's a lot of like if you look at red
heads and that true ginger's compared to
just a regular white person,
there's a lot of differences that you
would never even think of for some
reason.
Really.
Yeah.
What else?
Their eyes are usually more prone to.
They have to wear sunglasses.
Like it hurts their eyes more than where
they supposed to be from or they like
northern people don't know.
I have no idea.
You know what's crazy about Japan?
I went there about a year ago,
a year and a half ago this last time,
but they,
they're so down like they're number one
obsession as far as girls go.
Our school girls in the school,
girl outfits,
you know this.
That's number one,
but everybody knows that's crazy.
But number two is school girls in French
maid outfits,
so it's school girl and then French
made.
They have a bar out.
There were 15 year old,
14 year old girls dress up like friends,
like they're in the laundry and they're
serving ice cream.
Like it's totally okay in Japan.
It's insane.
Those guys are not.
I'm serious.
It's crazy.
They're obsessed with school girls and
little girls and French maid outfits and
just those two.
There's not even a third.
It's just,
are you fucking backstreet boys?
Are you in sync?
You got to choose sides,
you know,
and you have to have tentacles coming
out of you.
What's all that about?
They got some crazy animals.
I think it's a loophole to go and get
around there.
There are laws of insertion of canvases
and stuff.
Crazy cartoons.
Is that pipe before back in the day,
Roger.
Rabbit kidding me.
Come on.
Japanese penis porn.
That's crazy shit dude.
It's like giant digs going through a cig
and outer mouth and she's gagging and
slavery is everywhere.
There's dicks in her hands in each hand.
There's loads going all over the place.
It's some of the weirdest freaky shit
you've ever seen.
You can understand girls getting off to
it because I knew a girl once who loved
it,
but I just like cartoons.
See real shop,
two pluses with all dicks and they're
just fucking these crazy school girl
looking character.
You know,
like the final fantasy and you know,
find a fancy.
It's at CGI.
Where they're trying to make it look
real.
What's the best they've done it with in
porn like that?
What's the.
Is there anything?
Yeah,
like it'd be too expensive for porn,
but initiative used special effects for
like those themed ones.
Like they had an Avatar theme porn.
I'm sure they must have used some sort
of special effects.
The only ones I've seen are like,
they look totally fake,
but are there any that look almost real
time.
This is a waste of money,
man.
Who the hell is and you don't really
need to.
I mean,
unless there's someone out there that
you remember Salami.
So we had that movie.
No.
Yeah,
that's right.
Okay.
Forgot an inside story will be Salami
from A.
From a Jersey guy.
Yeah.
Bobby up Salami.
We call them Salami,
but not to be confused with the other
Salami.
Oh No,
no,
no.
This is Bobby Salami.
He was a pizza maker.
Peach mango.
Great Guy.
People who,
well make porn.
You know,
they,
there's,
there's that wish that they were
legitimate know I'm in.
I remember talking to Ron Jeremy a bunch
of times at the comedy store and
Robinson was telling me,
yeah,
I got a part in this thing and I'm
really excited.
I'm trying to go mainstream.
And I was like,
you're trying to go mainstream
mainstream show God damn.
And I'm like,
Dude,
you're Ron fucking Jeremy Man.
You're Ron Jeremy.
Like not a lot of dudes get to be Ron
Jeremy,
your ranch.
You're a bad motherfucker and you want
to be like one of these regular guys on
TV.
Yeah.
Scan.
And I was right there when you said that
it was in the parking lot at Hollywood
and highland.
And I was uh,
I just wasn't thinking and remember the
Dickish.
I mean that was the biggest douche.
Like when he started saying that it was
funny to me.
I'm like,
and I looked at Joe and I'm like,
can you imagine if it actually works?
And we see like Ron Jeremy doing like
diehard five and he's in a,
he's in a wife beater with a gun.
Someone's breaking in the house.
And I go,
whew.
Imagine drawn chairman was right there
and I started fucking laughing,
jealous,
like do,
don't laugh.
I looked at Ron Jeremy,
he's not laughing and I'm like,
Oh shit.
I just talked to mad shit right in front
of them.
I was,
I felt like shit.
Didn't realize it.
You thought that he would ever sense of
humor and that he'd be joking around
about it.
Like.
Because if you said that about Brian or
if he said that about joey or send above
anybody else.
So we know you said that about Ari.
Ari would joke around and pretend to be
a fucking action hero,
but when you say it about a guy who
really wants a legitimate career in
movies,
you know,
he was doing something with Roger.
Avery's like knocking on the door.
Roger Ray.
We had some sort of a TV show and he was
involved in it right before Roger Avery
got arrested for drunk driving.
So he was like in with like,
he wanted to be a movie star.
What if Ron,
Jeremy just says,
fuck it,
you know what?
I'm almost 50,
whatever the fuck it or whatever.
And then he gets into fucking beasel
shape if he got
into diesel shape,
like you just said,
fuck it.
That would ruin his whole appeal.
The whole appeal.
Ron.
Jeremy,
is it Ron Jeremy's and he's just banging
the hottest bitches and he'll tell.
He'll tell Ya.
Know Viagra.
I don't use Viagra.
I don't believe in it.
He will.
He won't.
He doesn't believe in it.
Yeah,
he's a savage.
The steroids have the porn world.
Like everyone denial.
They're all in denial,
but everybody's doing.
And do you know that the NFL is trying
to test for human growth hormone now?
There was a big thing.
I was watching the.
I never watched sports shows,
but they were talking to the head guy,
whoever the fucking head guy the NFL is.
And he's like,
yeah,
well we had.
That was a part of the bargaining that
we're going to test for human growth
hormone,
but the players representatives,
there's still a.
they're still debating the science,
the science of testing for human growth
hormone.
We believe the science is there.
And like what?
What are you talking about?
What are you going to have regular sized
people playing football?
Can you imagine it works and they
totally get steroids out of NFL.
It'd be so.
So you could be a 190 pounds and fucking
play defensive Lineman,
Rocky Marciano roll in his grave,
189 pound heavyweight champion of the
world.
That'd be hope for Mexicans and
football.
Right now we have one Mexican.
That'd be a lot of Mexicans,
man.
Well,
you know,
look at Mexican,
like Cain Velasquez.
He's a rare dude.
You know,
one of the 240 pounds ultra athlete who
moves fast.
He fucking moves fast and doubles
fastest.
Fuck.
What if he went to boxing and became the
world heavyweight champion in boxing?
There's nobody out there.
Oh,
I bet he could do it.
Well,
I don't know man,
if he'd have to deal with the
Klitschkos,
you know,
but I think he's one of those guys that
there's a few guys with their.
Their mind is so fucking strong.
Their work ethic is so strong and their
ability to pull shit off like Cain has
got this fucking wicked belief in
himself.
Man,
you could see it in that dude's eyes
before he goes out there and fights and
he's got that big ink and head,
you know what I mean?
And he's a fucking super athlete,
man.
You know,
he,
he doesn't look like,
you know,
your standard super athlete.
He doesn't have like super low body fat.
He doesn't have like a ridiculous six
pack and veins everywhere.
He doesn't look like a Kevin Randleman.
But that's also one of the reasons why
the motherfucker never gets tired.
That guy never gets tired.
He,
no one's got conditioning like Cain
Velasquez,
you know,
I think that God could do anything he
wants.
I think we're,
we're,
we're lucky to have him as a UFC
heavyweight champion,
but he would be whatever the fuck you
wanted to be.
If he wanted to play football,
he'd be playing football.
If you wanted to play,
if you want it to be a heavyweight
boxer,
he'd be a bad ass fucking heavyweight
boxer.
That guy's just,
he's just a killer.
There's certain dudes that are just
killer.
He should do like the cover of espn,
like in a chill outfit.
It's just rare that Mexicans are taking
this ride with it,
go with it.
With that,
with a baseball cap,
with the front flipped all the way up
like a suicidal tendency.
Dude,
you.
What do you think about junior dos
Santos and Cain Velasquez?
First of all,
I think how amazing it stop for a second
and think of how many Mexicans are
fucking bad ass fighters besides me are
counting everybody.
Youtube along with you,
but let's include like the boxers,
like Julio Cesar Chavez mean what?
That dude epitomized what like a bad ass
Mexican boxer was.
He would come out to the fucking
Mariachi music and he had the flag on
his fucking head and he would just Jack
People.
You know the days of Julio Cesar Chavez?
Man,
think about all the bad.
I mean,
it's amazing how many this Victoria t's
kid thinking about how many people who
are bad ass fires or of Mexican descent,
some amazing numbers.
Man.
I think it's,
it's Sarah,
the closest third world,
Latin country to Vegas.
You know,
it's the closest one.
You know what I mean?
You know,
because really Mexicans,
Guatemalans,
El Salvadorians,
Colombians felt the same shit.
Come on,
it's all there.
Just closest.
They're just the closest one in Las
Vegas and La.
But you know,
I'd love Mexico.
I'm Mexican in case you guys were all
pissed off,
but you know,
there's those borders out there.
It's all the same shit come on.
It is.
But the Mexicans figured out,
especially in boxing a way to be super
fucking successful,
you know,
I mean,
you,
you can't discount,
you know,
just say it's just all,
it's all the same shit because Mexicans
in particular have been really
successful at boxing.
You know,
they,
they've,
they've brought up some incredible
boxers out of Mexico and they have the
most loyal fans.
The Mexican fans are fucking not nuts.
Erik Morales.
And when that dude was on top,
God damn they go for the most Mexican
tick is when Julio Cesar Chavez was at
his prime when he fought Oscar de la
Hoya.
Well,
he was actually falling off as a little
bit and Oscar Delgado is rising.
You had to choose a side you want.
They all went with the most Mexican and
the Mexican Julio,
Cesar Chavez.
He couldn't even speak a word of
English.
He was a beast.
Yeah,
he was a fucking beast.
He would just body punch the fucking
shit out of you who just stay on top of
you until you eventually just broke you.
I was a giant boxing fan before the UFC.
I was like,
I was just a fanatic with boxing because
I was for mma and UFC and I loved them
both.
I saw Oscar de la Hoya,
his first pro fight at the La Forum.
I was a huge fan,
but I had to make a choice.
Fuck,
I chose.
I chose Julio.
Cesar Chavez.
I went to see a Berrera fight live.
I saw him fight live.
It was in la somewhere.
I want to say it's a stable center,
but it might've been before the staples
center even existed.
I don't know where the fuck I saw him,
but uh,
I saw him fight some other dudes,
some black dude that was pretty good.
But Berrera beat his ass and he,
we were all hanging out with Mexicans.
It's me and my friend Terry clay bond as
a boxing coach and we're all watching
this date.
They were going fucking bananas when
Barrera was going off.
They were going fucking bananas.
It's boxing is.
That's when the racism just fucking
comes out and it's okay.
It's okay to be racist if there's boxing
going on because when I met anytime of
Mexican fought,
anybody else I was.
I always went for the Mexican.
Even if it wasn't Mexican,
if he was Honduran and he was fighting a
white guy,
I'm going with a Latin guy.
That's the closest thing to Mexico.
I was.
It was okay with my best friend growing
up.
James.
He was black.
We were both into boxing.
He always went for the black guy.
I always went for the Mexican guy,
always.
He never went for the Mexican guy and I
went for the black guy that would and it
was okay.
It was,
but NMA job.
Totally different.
I can in MMA,
I can care less if the guys Mexican,
what I like.
Style style is way thicker than blood.
I'm a Jujitsu guy.
I'm always going.
I'm always pulling for the Jujitsu guys,
always.
I don't care if it's a black Jujitsu guy
against a kick boxer from Mexico from
where my mom was born.
Like,
fuck you,
I'm going for the Black Jujitsu guy.
It's always Jujitsu style.
You have to think that your Jujitsu
instructor,
it's styles way thicker than blood,
but boxing shit is.
A lot of people think that I pulled for
Jujitsu guys,
man,
but most of my favorite fighters are
strikers.
You know,
I pull for a pool for extra
extraordinary talent.
That's what I pulled for.
I don't pull for like individuals,
you know,
I pull,
I want to.
I want to see some crazy shit.
You know?
Even if it's a guy who I thought was
really good before,
then all of a sudden they pull something
off.
It's amazing.
It makes you look at them differently.
That's what my,
that's my favorite shit.
I like watching two guys push it off.
I just watched like watching guys
improve.
Guys that are really good.
You know,
I like just the best submission guys.
Those are always my friend Aoki.
He's always like that too.
But I still like watching Anderson man.
I like watching it.
You can't deny that.
I definitely.
I love knockouts.
Who Doesn't love a great knockout.
I love that shit too.
But I'm always pulling for cool new
submissions because there's so much room
for improvement and Jitsu and mma.
There's so much room.
It's still at its infancy.
You know,
there's something special to me.
I mean it's sounds kind of fucked up,
but there's something special to me when
a guy has reached the extraordinary
heights that like Anderson Silva has
that word and he's standing right in
front of you.
Chanel calming,
standing right in front of him with his
hands down,
his fist balled up,
and you just realize like,
this poor fucking mouse is in a box with
a Cobra and it's going to get jacked up.
It's going to get jacked.
You realize that you was trapped in
there with Anderson Silva.
It wasn't.
He was no longer competitive.
There was a moment after he had kicked
him at the end of the first round,
he fucking blasting and with a headache.
And from that moment on you,
she was not competitive.
He was,
Anderson knew it too.
There's no way you take one of those
head kicks and be okay.
I mean you might look okay,
you fall down,
you get back up,
you look okay,
but your shit is done.
You know,
Anderson just got in front of them and
started moving around on him and it was
just when you watch someone have that
skill level,
man,
I don't care what they're doing,
if they're doing boxing,
if they're doing Jujitsu,
if they're just kickboxing.
I just,
that's what I like.
I like watching someone is just hitting
those rare heights.
How about t j grant pulling guard with a
good team.
Dude pops his head out and switches to
that beautiful and oh,
it was amazing.
Even though there's controversy,
you know,
that he,
he didn't tap it all that.
There's some controversy there though.
But the fact that tj grant was so
confident in his guard that he pulled
guard with a good team because a lot of
guys don't like pulling guard with a
good thing because if,
if the guy pops his
head out and,
and,
and he gets out of the good,
oh you're on your back and he's on top.
But when clearly did it in a sequence,
the guy was defending with his left arm
and he knew he was going to get that
arm.
He knew it.
And as the guys defending shit,
it lets it go and goes to the arm bar.
He was so confident of.
So few fighters are.
They're just not confident I'll fighting
off their backs.
You know,
there's so many Brazilian black belts
out there moon our champion too.
They just refused to pull guard.
They don't,
they don't feel like,
you know,
I don't know what they're thinking,
but to me it just seems like they don't
have enough confidence in the guard had
been doing Jujitsu for a long time.
And it's refreshing to see someone like
Tj grants.
Like,
you know what?
I'm having trouble taking this guy down.
Let me just pull guard and attack off my
back.
Well,
he almost got him with an arm bar and
the,
uh,
the first round he had locked up an arm
bar and went belly down at the very last
second.
So the first roundup,
he's a beast man at one thing that kids
a killer t j grant.
I knew he was talented when I first used
fought real tony and his UFC debut.
That's a tough fight for UFC debut.
Anyone want a decision?
I'm like,
this fucking kids.
How about Paul Sas?
He hasn't fought in like a year and he's
like,
the first I've ever heard of Paul Sassy
was finding on the undercard in an
England show over a year ago.
And it was a headline on the underground
and said the headline was I'd like to
fall up,
fight off my back.
I'm like,
you never have seen that as a headline
for a fighter in some interview.
I liked to fight off.
My back is so dangerous.
Offers back.
And then I'm like,
wow,
let me watch this guy.
I go,
this guy pulls guard.
So his in the fight a year and a half
ago in England,
he pulled,
he shoots,
pulls,
guard,
attacks off his back.
The guy stands up,
pulls away,
runs away.
They stand up again still first round,
he shoots deep,
makes the guy sprawl,
pulls guard,
attack some.
The guy pulls out of Inova bladder or
triangle.
They go again.
Third time he shoots,
pulls,
guard,
goes after like a leg lock.
He just misses it.
Bam.
Or something like that.
Instill in the first round.
He shot again for a fourth time shot the
dude sprawled.
He pulled guard and then he got them.
He got them like there's a guy out there
named Paul Sas who so confident on
fighting his back and he's people don't
want anything to do with his guard.
He sits on his ass and says,
come on,
get on top.
I'm spotting you.
I'm good.
I'm spotting.
You guys will refuse to get in his
guard.
You would think.
They're like,
damn,
this guy is going to go on his back.
I'm just gonna.
Go on top and just mash them.
I can't believe he's just submitting and
just going on his back.
His guard is so dangerous guys.
The hard part is getting guys to agree
to get into his guard.
That's unique.
That's fascinating to me.
I love seeing that.
Paul says,
Tj Grant,
man,
I'm huge fans of those guys.
Well,
what what it is is that people are
realizing that there's a level that's
possible to achieve that hasn't been
demonstrated yet and there's a lot of
those people in straight Jujitsu and
there's a lot of those people in the
street submission grappling,
but in an mma when you add in all the
other things,
we haven't seen anybody pull it off.
We haven't ever ever seen like the way
Marcello Garcia went through all those
competitors in Abu Dhabi in 2003 when we
first saw Marcello in person.
I'll be like,
this guy is like a speed demon.
The way he was going through people like
the banality to his technique was so
clean.
Yeah,
but that's.
You know,
it's a different world when you add in
wrestling and when you add in punching
and you had a nice and kicks and this is
a different world.
We haven't quite seen someone hit those
heights of submission.
We're starting to see it though.
There are.
There are a handful of fighters that
have zero problem pulling guard and
Vinny Maga classes.
One he used to fight in the UFC.
He wasn't one of the seasons of tough.
He pulls guard like he doesn't mind.
His guard is so dangerous that he will
pull garden and attack you and you know
that again,
there's Paul Sassy.
Paul South fought last week.
He did the exact same thing.
He pulled guard guy pulled out of an arm
bar or a triangle and then you switch it
to a leg lock.
It was a beautiful leg lock.
So um,
and then like Aoki will pull guard
anytime.
But you see Matt Wyman and Mac Dancer.
That was amazing.
I had,
why am I got Mac dancing and a fucking
serious arm bar.
He didn't tap him,
but I'm like whoa.
That was quick.
He had hit a nice arm bar for his back.
If Mac Danzig didn't have such good
defense,
he woulda got that.
We're starting to see more and more
fighters beat active once they get put
on their back,
like if they got put on their back and
they didn't want to be there.
Like Miguel Torres,
if he gets put on his back,
he will attack.
You just not going to sit there.
Havi Vasquez.
He's just not going to sit there.
He says he's going to attack you.
And then the,
you know,
and then you got guys like,
uh,
you know,
rumble Johnson who wants to be on top of
rumble.
Johnson had a guard to rumbled,
Johnson's frightening.
And you see that fight with Charlie
Brennan.
He's terrifying.
His eyes look orange.
I wonder if he's wearing contacts.
He's had surgery on his eyes.
Is that what it is?
Poked.
He got poked really bad by Kevin Burns.
Remember Kevin Burns could not close his
lefthand.
Kevin Burns broke his left hand so many
times that he literally couldn't close
it.
So he would like Paul with his left and
then throw his right and he poked the
fucking shit out of his eyes.
Anthony Johnson's a Jesus.
He's scary.
He's a,
he's a true super athlete.
You know,
he's a,
first of all the idea that that guy can
get the 70.
It's like it defies logic defies.
It defies reason.
You know,
you look at them and you go,
you see them in between fights.
Like that's a heavyweight,
that's a goddamn heavyweight.
And then somehow or another it makes one
70 and he looks fucking great the day of
whatever he's doing and he's doing it
right.
You know,
I just wonder if it takes so much out of
him that it would.
I mean,
I think what he does at one 70,
he could probably do it one 85 to.
I think he might even feel better if it
was doing it at 1:35,
you might feel healthier.
You know,
I,
I don't know.
I mean I'm only just taking wild stabs
at it.
[inaudible] I don't think it's so good
to cut that much weight for so long.
I think it's terrible for your body,
but whatever the fuck he's doing,
man,
when he gets in there,
very few guys move as quick as that guy
does.
Very few guys,
when he's like,
when we were siting Charlie Brennan,
you know,
he didn't respect Brennaman standup that
much.
She was worried about his wrestling,
but he knew that he had a big standup
advantage.
You could tell he was in the confidence
that he had when he moved forward and I
was watching.
I was like,
that is terrifying.
That guy,
when he's confident,
when he's confident and he's.
He's real,
real short is going to tag you.
Like he was the finals of tough when he
fought that Tommy spirits kid,
when he's real confident that his
standup is way better than you.
He's so dangerous.
He's one of the scariest guys at one 70.
Even scarier than Tiago thiago.
Alves is probably the best technical
striker,
but Anthony Johnson,
when he gets you hurt,
he's the scariest guy.
He's a scariest.
He's,
I think he's got like a gnarly
potential.
You know,
I think what you've seen now,
it's like,
that guy's going to get better.
He's getting better already.
He's just,
he's just a freak,
fucking awesome athlete.
You know,
that's racialist.
No,
that's just reality,
man.
If he was white,
I'd say the same goddamn thing.
Whatever he's doing,
he's doing awesome.
I mean there's,
you know,
it's hard work and discipline for sure.
Go into all any recipe for success.
But that guy is a,
he's a special athlete.
He's,
he's built the fuck people up.
You know,
this is a good sport for him.
there's certain guys like John Jones
always says that he can't fucking throw
a football.
He's not,
he's not good at basketball.
You can't dunk,
but Goddamn as he designed perfect for
mma,
you know,
Jon Jones has the literally the perfect
frame.
You know,
that that's the.
If you look at all the people that are
fighting right now and all the different
equations,
you know,
how would you get to this guy?
How would you beat that guy?
What are you going to do?
You get to John Jones,
you go,
damn,
good luck.
And I love the fact that the navy,
and I'm not a striker,
like I said,
I'm a fan of striking.
It was a big boxing fan.
I love that.
More and more fighters are starting to
implement taekwondo and Kung Fu kinks.
I love that.
You know,
and guys like John Jones and Anderson
Silva,
they're doing Kung Fu there.
They're throwing wing Chung kicks,
that taekwondo kicks and that one got 45
does it.
Dustin Dennis,
the guy was just an awesome kicker.
Dustin Dennis Doonas,
I'm sure.
Yeah,
he's at 45.
He fought hoodie fine.
He Find Florian.
Kenny Florian.
Oh,
Diego Nunez.
Diego knew he's a sales guy.
Watch him over one young guy.
Yeah.
That guy can kick.
He's got great kick Nova and Y'all guys
married.
A lot of those guys are wicked kickers.
I would say a good 80 percent,
85 percent of of MMA fighters today are
just throwing the basic,
you know,
tight leg kick and then a head kick.
Occasionally.
Maybe a spinning back kick or something.
I love guys to just throw it all,
throw it all.
Well,
usually those guys have a taekwondo or
karate background because in in,
in normal mma training,
man,
it's way harder to teach someone how to
throw a sidekick then as how to teach
them and throw a round kick.
Yeah.
I could teach you to throw a low kick
and throw it correctly in a couple of
and in any normal athlete football
player,
a baseball player,
any normal athlete can perform that,
but if I say or I do a,
we'll kick.
I want you to do a.
we'll kick with power like Jesus Christ.
That takes a long time to learn it.
If you're.
Even.
If you're a super athlete,
it's going to take a while to pick up.
Let Jon Jones is throwing it.
Well,
of course with John Jones,
he's training for quite awhile now.
What I'm saying is it's like it's not
easy to pick up those certain techniques
like sidekicks.
That's the.
John's got a wicked sidekick now too,
man.
It's got a front leg.
Scientificky hops forward to he.
He was throwing,
Spinning back X.
He.
He threw a hopping sidekick against the
cage and they'll just a warm up.
Like I was using warming up and I'm
like,
Whoa,
he's doing it perfectly.
Knee up high,
turning the hip.
[inaudible] pretty much proved that you
know,
all of those Kung Fu kicks or to work
Connolly's got the best threesixty
turning side kick in the game,
you know,
and that's one of his sidekicks or one
of the things that makes his fight with
vandelay so interesting because when
American kickboxer started fighting tie
fighters,
they found two things out.
The one they found out how difficult it
is to deal with leg kicks.
They were getting fucked up by leg
kicks,
but guys like Don Wilson,
who was a he,
he learned leg kicks early on and he
fought a lot of leg kick fights.
He realized how good the front leg side
kick was.
The front leg roundhouse kick it kicks
it.
The ties weren't that good at ties would
throw the team,
but they would get close enough to each
other.
Jack each other's legs.
And when you fight that style,
where you kick the legs,
you don't necessarily develop the
techniques like the karate techniques,
because the chronic techniques,
a lot of them,
when you're coming up through the ranks,
they kind of get shut down.
But you know by a lot of the Thai
techniques.
But if you learn karate before you learn
more tie,
then you have all that crazy dexterity
for acs kicks,
we'll kicks and all that shit.
That may be one work as well.
If guys were kicking your legs so you
might have a more conservative game.
You know,
some guys that come up through the
taekwondo ranks,
those are the ones who do wild,
crazy shit because you can't get punched
in the face and taekwondo tournament.
So those guys,
when those guys get into Moitai,
that's Diego Nunez.
That's Anderson Silva.
That's also Edson Barboza.
They got all that shit in their back
pocket.
Yeah,
that Edson Barboza Guy.
So you would say you would say that it's
for kids.
They're dreaming about being UFC
champions to do some taekwondo for a few
years just to get,
get all that.
The crazy kicks down.
And stay balanced and maybe not even do
taekwondo by itself,
but incorporate a couple of days of
taekwondo training into your training,
like say if you were a new kid and you
were trying to become an mma fighter,
what you should do is at least one day a
week work on kicks because one of the
things you could do by working on these
wild kicks is forget about the sparring,
forget whatever.
Then you just want to work on a
technique and a kick and learn how to
kick things.
Learn how to stretch out that front leg
side kick learned to wheelchair,
learn the ax kick.
Once you do it,
if you do it with someone who's really
good at it,
you see like the high level techniques
you see when someone and then that's
what you mirror and your mind and that's
what you try to recreate
and that's how you get really good at
those things.
When you add in kicks,
a lot of those techniques go out the
window.
When you add in punches,
a lot of those leg kicks,
excuse me,
allows techniques go out the window.
You add in punches,
a lot of those techniques go out the
window.
You had to take downs.
A lot of those techniques go go out the
window in less,
you know how to check kicks,
block takedowns,
and you have good boxing,
so you have to have all those other
things.
Then you can use the taekwondo again
because then you have all these other
techniques.
Then it's just another tool for the
arsenal,
but unless you have a fully rounded
game,
those tools become problems like the
kicks.
You rely on them too much and you drop
your hands.
You get punched in the face because
you're not used to being punched in the
face,
so you have to develop good,
good timing and distance for punches as
well as kicks.
You have to change your game,
but once you do change your game,
so that's the beauty of adding it in as
like one day a week or two days a week
where you just constantly work on only
those techniques.
Then you're doing all that other stuff
too,
so you might actually be able to pull
them off.
I think eventually what we're going to
have to have is there's going to be like
a system,
you know,
when they train football players,
and they,
they,
they don't just just take a lucky guess
like,
today we're going to do this,
you know,
well,
I don't know that it's going to help
you,
but today I want you to chop wood with
an ax.
You know,
today,
maybe it'll help if you pick up bags of
sand,
you know,
that.
No,
they don't do that.
They,
they know what the fuck they're doing
when they're training football players,
they know what they're doing when
they're preparing plays,
they know what they're doing.
You know when,
when guys are,
you know,
they're monitoring guys performances and
measuring their time,
their distance,
you know,
when they're running the 40 are running
100.
They were there trying to figure out
what is the,
what's the best way to optimize
athleticism.
The eventually that's going to happen
and it's going to be a scientific
approach to mma training.
And there's gonna be a bunch of
different approaches.
You know,
everyone's gonna have their own little
style to do it,
but there's gonna.
It's going to get to a point where we
know exactly how many hours you're
supposed to train in a day before.
It's detrimental.
We know that even though you can do it,
you know,
five hours a day,
you shouldn't do it five hours a day.
It fucks you up.
We know what's the right amount,
what is the exact program you should be
on as far as striking,
what does he,
what are the exact lessons you should be
learning every day because that's how it
should be treated.
It should be treated as something you're
trying to develop like a project you're
developing and it should be micromanage.
You should manage every single aspect of
it.
You should manage all the hold.
You should objective,
analyze all the different techniques,
all your vulnerabilities and sparring.
Would body types,
give you problems,
all that shit.
It has to be treated like a science in
order to really truly optimize it.
Then you add in creativity and you know
the ability to improvise,
improvise,
and the ability to fight hard and the
ability to be disciplined and get in
shape,
but eventually we're going to get to
that point where people are getting so
good like these rory Mcdonald's of the
world,
these young kids that are coming up,
they're so fucking good.
You see them improving every time you
see them,
they're way better.
You're like,
wow.
Eventually it's going to be.
It's going to have to be down to a
science because you're going to deal
with the.
The abilities that people are going to
have are going to be so fucking high
level.
You know at the very top we're going to
see guys that we can't even imagine
because we haven't seen them yet.
We haven't.
We're going to look back on even like
Vito Belfort or guys of this era that
are devastating.
We're going to look back on them and
say,
boy,
but if they fought the guise of 2030,
they'd probably get fucked up.
You know the same way people look at
Rocky Marciano and go,
what the fuck is Rocky Marciano?
And you're going to do the Vitaly
Klitschko fatality Klitschko seven feet
fucking tall is he's got a telephone
pole for a job and it would just blast
that poor little dude in the head all
day until he fell unconscious.
No,
and that's what we're going to look back
on.
Now.
We're going to look back on it.
The greats like GSP.
We're going to look back on him.
Now,
one day,
you know in the future where there's
going to be some super fucking freak
athlete who you think would probably
beat GSP fairly easily.
It's gonna Happen,
man.
It's going to happen in all the way
classes were in the middle of the
fucking stream right now.
We haven't even come close to the dam.
We're not even close to the full limits
of human potential.
You think about the kind of freak
athletes that they have in basketball.
We wait until those all guys,
those all start fighting MMA fights.
Think about some of the amazing
specimens that choose to play baseball
because they're good sprinters and they
could run around,
uh,
the,
the basis real quickly,
what if those guys decided to start
fighting,
you know,
those are the,
those are the real freak athletes.
Like I was telling you.
I mean,
I've been doing Jujitsu a long time and,
and when you trained,
you get to even a couple of years,
you know,
if you're going against a wrestler,
you role with someone,
you're like,
damn,
did you wrestle,
you know,
they feel like a whole different person.
And you know,
after awhile after doing it for 10,
15 years,
you get really,
really good at gauging someone's
strength and you know,
kind of guessing what kind of athletic
background they had or if they,
you know,
I brought with soccer players due to the
dudes that played soccer their whole
life.
And I'm like,
wow,
they got some strong passing strong
hips,
you know.
And a year ago I opened 10 planet Vista
and that's,
that's,
uh,
that's in San Diego County.
And inside a 10th planet.
This,
that they have a dance studio too.
It's like,
you know,
in my studio we have pole dancers.
Every,
every academy has their own little
flavor down at Vista they have a break
dancing.
It's like a new eclectic breakdancing,
the combines,
Kung Fu,
break dancing,
yoga,
double load of stuff,
and it's all based on getting into
double load is,
it's,
it's a trip.
So it's like rubber guard,
breakdancing.
Well there's a group out there,
they've been dead for people that don't
know Double Lotus for the folks who
don't know is like a yoga position where
you have one foot and then you wrap the
other foot over onto the other needs.
Very difficult to get into for the
average unflexible person.
It's like a super flexible Indian style
type thing.
Yes,
that's good way of putting it.
And uh,
you know,
the school opened and right away other
breakdancer started taking Jujitsu and
there's one lead.
Breakdancers name is Gio.
He calls himself freak show and after
two months of training he,
he goes onto himself freak show that the
whole,
the whole thing's a freak show.
It's like a,
it's like a bad name.
They're a group freak show.
When you roll with them,
you're going to feel a little freak
show.
It's incredibly.
It's 145 pounds and after training two
months he did the gracie nationals and
it looked like,
you know,
he did beginners division,
but it looked like he was sandbag and he
was just gone right through.
Dude there was incredible and I thought,
wow,
what's this guy gonna look like in a
couple of years?
Well,
a year,
a year later,
Sean ballinger is one of my black belt.
He is the one who certified that school.
He gave him a purple belt after one
year.
And I'm like,
wow,
I mean,
how good is this guy getting now?
So I invited him in all his breakdancers
over to headquarters,
my school here in La and they,
you know,
he had a year experience and was already
a purple belt.
And I'm like,
hmm,
this guy is like a really is a frequent.
Let me see what he feels like.
So I rolled with them and it was
incredible.
I'd never felt,
you know,
if a guy told me,
he wrestled his whole life and he's been
doing Jujitsu a year,
I would have a way easier time with that
guy than I did,
especially when he weighs 140,
100,
45 pounds.
It was incredible.
I've never felt anything like this and
even the guys that were on a squad that
were training eight months,
10 months size turbo and ozone,
that I'd never felt anything like this.
It was incredible.
It would you say turbo and ozone.
So what that mean?
That's from the movie breaking.
Those were two.
So these,
these exercises that they do,
it's like at all,
they're doing one handed handstands
getting into flying,
double loaded.
They're balancing on their head without
spinning.
You know,
the old school break dancers would spin
and then they would balance like a top.
They just get on their head and their
balance is so extraordinary.
It's unbelievable.
They do like cirque Cirque du Solei
stuff.
Cirque du Solei is the only time that I
can ever remember as a man feeling low.
I went with a chick and as I was in the
audience watching and I felt inadequate,
I felt like I can't do that.
These guys like,
you know,
I,
I think of myself as being a guy who was
in good shape.
I'm fit.
I work out all the time and I'm watching
these guys move around.
I'm like,
Whoa,
that guy just is doing a one handed
handstand.
His legs are going that way and he's
holding another man up in the air above
him.
Yeah.
Huggies is fucking.
It was the craziest thing ever.
Like the idea that someone can be that
physically strong,
they're doing one hand in hand stands
and I got this on video,
video taped everything,
all those guys.
It was unbelievable that they get on one
hand,
handstands,
get into flying,
double load is and start jumping and
hopping.
On one hand.
It's incredible when you feel like how
strong they are and I'm convinced that
come,
you know,
a lot of people separate balance
exercises and then core exercises.
I think there's something about
combining core extreme core training,
like they're doing all these handstands
and balancing and then combining extreme
balance.
You put them together.
I think that really does create a whole
new animal because I've never felt
anything like this.
It's combining core exercises and
extreme balance.
At the same time turns your body into
something different.
It totally makes sense.
Something about it,
you know,
the ability to manipulate your body at
an extreme in an extreme way.
Yoga alone makes you better at
everything you do athletically.
It gives you much more control and much
more.
You know,
uh,
just you have,
you have a finer degree of movement
where you can,
you can balance yourself better.
You have more,
but that's way harder than yoga.
Yeah,
it's,
it's incredible.
It's extreme yoga because there's a lot
of yoga.
There's their style is,
is a combination of everything they're
doing.
They're bringing Kung Fu and they're
bringing break dance and they're
bringing yoga,
putting it all together,
and like Cirque du Solei.
It's incredible.
These guys,
these guys are incredible.
I have seen some break dancers do some
wild ass fucking Kung Fu kicks.
They call themselves the freak show,
man.
I've seen breakdancers do those flying
flip kicks where they flipped through
the air and throw kicks at the same
time.
Obviously the way I look at is you need
a lot more bass in wrestling than you do
in Jujitsu and Jujitsu's.
The level of basis that's required is
not nearly as much as wrestling.
Wrestling is all about getting that top
position.
It's all about balance.
It's all about base,
but this style of breakdancing requires
like 10 times more base than a rustler
to do all these crazy things.
The base and the balances it's required.
It's crazy.
So when they come back down and do
Jujitsu,
like the hardest part in Jujitsu is
getting the base and the balance.
The movies are actually fairly easy to
learn.
You could show a nine year old girl a
rear naked choke and they could learn it
in like five minutes or less.
It's the balance and putting it all
together and the coordination and the
dexterity and man,
when they come down.
And did you get so once they learned
that the basic object of the game and a
couple passes,
it's extraordinary.
It really is.
That's amazing.
What W,
what does that turns out to be the the
workout,
extreme gymnastics or stream
breakdancing.
I'm infusing that they're going to be so
entertaining.
You know what I mean?
It's going to be like choreographed.
This is the beginning of.
This is the beginning of the infusion of
this style of exercise into the 10th
planet system.
I'm definitely.
I'm sold.
I'm like,
I'm at the gym weightlifting.
I've been doing Jujitsu for 17 years and
I'm doing squats and doing
weightlifting.
Yes,
I'm,
I'm.
I'm stronger than if I wasn't doing it.
But when you roll with a guy that's been
doing Jujitsu a year and he just feels
any,
and I got 20 pounds on him,
it's pretty extraordinary.
Everybody like respond first told me.
He goes,
he went down there and did a seminar.
dude,
if he rolled that Geo kid yet and I go,
no dude,
I couldn't get that guy.
That guy's watch way to.
Well with them.
It's incredible and it's not just him.
Like I said,
the other guys,
there were small dudes too that we're
been doing Jujitsu eight months,
10 months and yeah,
I was getting them,
but dude,
I was going 100 percent.
It should have been really,
really easy.
It wasn't really easy.
That's amazing.
It's incredible,
man.
So I'm.
I'm starting already.
I'm like,
my balance is terrible.
I can't do handstands,
but I'm practicing
against walls.
I'm going to slowly infuse that into the
system.
I'm going to make that my workout.
You don't also heard is really good too,
is polities.
I think someone has a police for
grapplers who doesn't want to loiter
ones?
Dude,
dudes have a place for grapplers DVD out
or something like that.
Hmm.
I don't know,
but I read something about plays online.
There's some athlete.
It was looking to do something relaxing
in between seasons.
He started doing pilates and who's
talking about how ridiculously hard it
is and people think it's easy because
chicks are doing it but polite,
especially for a man to carry,
you know,
carrying a different amount of weight.
You know,
Palantir is supposed to be super awesome
for you.
There's a lot of different things you
can do.
It's amazing how like pliable and
developable,
developable engineerable the body is.
Hey,
you can force it to do certain things
like,
think of like,
look,
I'm a perfect example,
like growing up doing taekwondo and my
body's still can do all that crazy shit.
You know,
even if I took years off,
you got to pee.
Your body adapts,
your body adapting.
It fits into a couch perfectly when you
talk about,
um,
about being worried about your health as
you get older.
Man,
why don't you stop smoking cigarettes?
Because it's awesome.
I love it.
It was really that good.
So great.
Why don't you try cigars that's worse
for you?
That's like,
I don't think seeing all the fucking
cancer into your mouth and throat and
gums.
I don't think it is.
I think,
um,
I think it gives you a little nicotine
fix.
That's all.
Phil Hartman quit.
Quit smoking cigarettes or smoking
cigars and I go to Jeff's smoke all day.
He goes,
no,
I smoked one or two a day at the most.
He just,
uh,
he just gives you a little fix and then
you can slowly wean yourself off of it
because what you're really hooked on,
according to people online,
I don't know if it's true,
what you're really hooked on is not just
the tobacco,
but the 599 additives that the way
they've got it engineered.
If you can still get tobacco into your
system and nicotine into your system,
you can slip away from the grips of
addiction slowly.
They say it takes 10 years off your life
though,
and it's like,
Ah,
who cares?
Who wants to live the extra 10 years of
your life?
That's not what it is.
It makes,
makes.
When you're 50,
you feel like you're 60,
you're 60,
you feel like you're 70.
It doesn't just take 10 years off your
life.
It makes you feel really old,
shitty.
You're,
you're,
you're cooking your body.
Enjoy it.
If you like it,
you say you love it,
enjoy it.
Do you take vitamins and try to
counteract the cigarettes?
Uh,
I've been juicing and I've been doing
the juice thing.
Wake up and do how many cigarettes a
day?
Pack a whole pack now.
God Damn Son,
you were only about 10 cigarettes a day
for a while,
but that was right after I quit when I
started back up again.
Because when you start back up,
you don't go right to the full pack.
He slowly go,
I'm only smoking 10 a day and then next
thing I know you're smoking,
you should go and do that Ibogaine Shit.
I began for treatment.
Does that work for from supposed
to be amazing for any addictions?
Not all of them.
Does their certain pills that have done
like it doesn't work on Benzos.
Really?
Yeah.
There's certain things like I for some
reason it has something to do with
alcohol.
Like in Brazil,
the people that are part of the IOWASCA
religions,
they give their kids at 14 Iowasca to
prevent them from being an alcoholic.
So that's real shit.
So would that make sense?
Well,
I think that's because it's insightful
because it lets you see.
It lets you experience a deep spiritual
connection with the mother earth and
then you don't.
You don't want to be a fucking loser,
you know when you,
when you're in the presence of some form
of divinity,
whatever the fuck the spirit of the Iowa
is,
whatever it is that when you have that
like crazy experience,
whatever the fuck you're in,
the presence of you,
that that presence affects you forever.
I mean that's essentially what these
people are saying that as John Hopkins
University study,
it changes their personality.
It makes them money.
And when you had.
I heard that Graham Hancock podcast and
when you guys were talking about
Iowasca,
you guys were talking about how the
spirit of Iowasca or whatever it is,
is female and you guys were into the,
the,
whatever you call it,
the spirit world or,
or whatever that Iowasca dimension is.
What do you think that is?
Thank
you know when you were talking about
there's information around us all the
time and if we could have goggles that
could see all the fucking ones and
zero's flying through the air and all
the cellular signals and all the Wifi
and I think it's very likely that we are
just at a stop on the dial and that the
reality of infinity is that there is a
unlimited number of frequencies to tune
into and it's not as simple as you know,
we live in one.
I mean we know according to quantum
physicists and I don't understand it,
but I'll repeat what they say is that
there are 11 dimensions,
11 known dimensions,
provable somehow or another by some
mathematics that I'll never understand.
So if that's the case,
what does that mean?
If we know that we have time and space
and we know that the basic dimensions
that we're comfortable with,
what the fuck are these other ones?
What the fuck is what?
What is,
what are those and how do we know that
this is just one sort of discovery on
the way to discovering that,
oh no,
this is a part of another fractal and
there are infinite numbers of different
dimensions because that to me seems just
as likely as it's more than one.
I have a feeling that there's just an
unlimited number of them,
but we exist in one dimension.
We don't understand the other ones.
We can't tune into them and part of our
brain can and part of our brain,
Ken,
when we sleep and part of our brain can
and we think of we think of traveling as
a physical act of moving your tissue and
your cells and your bones from one space
to another space,
but that's silly.
What the fuck is imagination?
What are thoughts?
What are ideas?
What are language?
These are all things that are in the
air.
These are all things that travel from
people to people in the air,
but they create things and things become
of them and in empires get built because
of using words and all this stuff comes
from the human imagination and the human
imagination is what tunes in when you're
sleeping and it's where all these
psychedelic compounds that are all
created by your own body.
They'd all interacts with all that shit
and that's how things get done and that
is why there is creativity that that is
the source of all of it.
The human imagination,
the human mind is the source of all this
craziness that we say good and bad
based on all that,
like all that craziness.
What do you think?
What would you guess?
Like,
I think it's another.
When you die,
what do you think happened?
I think you'd go right to that DMT
world,
man.
You think your soul is eternal triggered
guessing,
but if you.
If you had to,
if you had to guess,
you would think the soul is eternal.
This is what I think
the idea of you dis.
It just stops,
stops it ends.
I think the only reason why you and I or
I and all of us,
anybody listening,
the only reason why we think of
ourselves as one is because of our ego
and it's because of our desire to
protect our biology and to breed.
We are.
We are programmed to seek out a breeding
partner and reproduce.
It's all natural and it's all chemical
and then there's all sorts of roles that
we play in society to ensure that the
best genetics and the ones that are
moving forward the most are the ones
that get to breed the most and it's all
like simple and scientific and it all
seems to me to be a part of some sort of
an engineered system,
an engineered system that's guaranteed
to produce certain certain
results.
You know,
bacteria,
they have their job in.
You know,
every cell has its job,
but they don't really.
They're not really.
You wouldn't think the bacteria is
conscious of what it's doing to our
bodies.
It's very important.
Do you think like in this dimension,
we're going around with their own lives,
watching tv,
doing our own thing,
but on the other side,
in another dimension,
what we're doing,
our our energy,
our frequency is important to what is
going on the other side.
We might be a cold,
we might be a cold for another
dimension.
Yeah,
that's what we might be.
We might be the negative energy that
creeps through the cracks and Fox with
their world because we're polluting our.
That's.
It just sounds like super old drug.
Crazy sophisticated and complicated and
so complex.
Well organized,
you know,
it's just like.
It's sounds very intelligent,
doesn't it?
Well,
I don't.
I wouldn't say intelligent,
but I would definitely say it follows a
very specific direction,
you know?
I mean whether or not it's aware of that
direction is another question entirely
and I think that that's really
debatable.
I think that I don't think fucking
caterpillars aware that it's going to
become a butterfly and I don't think a
human being isn't necessarily aware of
why the fuck all what all we're doing is
we're moving towards a certain direction
knowing we're not knowing it,
so I wouldn't say it's intelligent.
I would say it's a direction.
It's a very specific direction.
The only time
I feel like a contact with intelligence,
like real divine intelligence is
psychedelic experiences.
Those are the only time I feel humbled
by something.
What however the fuck it is way smarter
than me,
even if it's just some sort of a
chemical reaction in my mind.
Boy,
the ultimate wisdom displayed by that
chemical reaction is not just tangible,
but it it.
You carry it with you the rest of your
life.
You carry those thoughts and what you've
learned from those experiences the rest
of your life,
and that's what they found is John
Hopkins study on Siliciden mushrooms and
that's what you've experienced in your
life.
That's what I've experienced in my life.
You can't tell me it's not happening
that way.
You,
you're,
you're tuning into some other.
In incredible intelligence.
And you're going,
oh,
okay.
Like I was taking myself seriously.
I was being ridiculous.
I was thinking that was important.
I was thinking I was special.
I was thinking I was,
you know,
I was right.
And everyone's wrong.
Like Whoa,
you don't know Jack Shit and you have a
few of those and you feel that I had
this crazy dream a couple of weeks ago.
Uh,
I,
I was,
me and my girlfriend were at the house I
grew up in and she's in the back yard
screaming.
It's nighttime.
It's,
it's late at night.
She's screaming,
come back here,
come back here.
And I felt like something was wrong with
the baby or something.
So I run out in the,
in the,
in the backyard and she's looking up at
the sky and then I look up in the sky
and then you see all these intelligent
shooting stars like,
like it was full disclosure.
It's like all these low beams of light,
like with Algorithms and equations and
chem trails in this fancy hand writing
and chem trails in like hieroglyphics
and all the answers.
And we're just standing there going,
shit,
all the equations,
it just came out like,
what,
what the hell on what were you on?
I was dreaming.
But what?
Did you take anything before you went to
bed?
No,
not.
I mean I smoked weed but I didn't take
Alpha brain.
Eddie will give you a crazy lucid dream
alpha brain commercial right there.
And Alpha brain gives you crazy lucid
cut that shit.
And Howard,
will you take an Alpha brand when you
have that?
No,
I've been taking.
I want you to have an extra bottle of
wine.
I want.
I want your honest,
unbiased opinion about.
Definitely.
So what,
what would fucking happen if like there
was just full disclosure,
like you just hear like aliens from the
next star system just said,
okay,
this is what's going down.
You've been part of this,
you know,
breeding or,
or whatever.
You're part of this galactic federation.
It's 2012,
this is what's going on.
And the whole history of us was just
thrust upon us.
Well imagine if our entire civilization
was just the interstellar version of
seaworld were seaworld for aliens.
Exactly,
so you find this out and they tell you,
they tell you,
I'm not only want to get into it because
it's just you don't want to get into it.
What do you mean?
No,
it's just I don't want to get into it,
but it just,
man,
what?
What's going to happen will happen
eventually.
You said you don't want to get into it.
That's
a long story.
This guy came in the room and he started
taking off his clothes and I started
slowly.
Secondly,
how would people react if,
because if the entire truth,
what if it wasn't even aliens?
What if like our government said,
okay,
this is what's going on.
This is the history of the solar system
is the history of the Galactic
Federation.
We're actually part of this giant
federation.
We were just left alone for a few
hundred thousand years to get to a
certain point.
Now we're part of this.
Now we need to move everybody to another
planet because asteroids coming,
so we need to get on some fucking God
damn ships and you know what I mean?
Like,
could you imagine if [inaudible]
actually came from the ocean?
What if they all come from the ocean?
What if we don't know it?
Use teligent.
There's an intelligent species that is
like way older than us that figured out
the best way to exist is to dig trenches
deep into the ocean.
They have these deep underwater
civilization so they're completely cut
off from all the rest of the fish and
all the wildlife,
so they got completely removed from the
food chain,
much like we did by not living in the
jungles and we moved in the cities.
They just built these fucking things
down under ground and they became super
sophisticated and they control their
environment like no other animal in the
ocean and they built fucking ships and
shoot those ships out.
Another actually octopus and all the
octopus that we see,
the ones that got away with spongebob.
If something came from another planet,
if something was so smart that it came
from another planet,
you would think that it would be able to
hide itself.
You would think we're going to figure
that out before we figure out
interplanetary travel.
We're going to figure out cloaking
because if you pay attention,
they're pretty close to clogging.
They figured out a way to make a tank
that the broadcast something,
it projects it on the side of the tank
so it looks like the walls behind it.
It's fucking crazy shit.
It's crazy shit.
So they're.
They're pretty close to figuring out how
to do that and make it look really good
because if you think about the first one
megapixel camera,
I had one dude,
it was a brick,
was a one megapixel digital camera and
it was a brick and now your phone has an
eight megapixel camera or more about
when they master your thoughts and your
dreams and you could sell your dreams
and like bad ass dudes that are lucid,
lucid dreamers and they create amazing.
It's like fuck watching movies like
movies or from moving.
It's like watching a martial arts movie
like you want to mma now.
Why are we going to watch Jeff Speakman?
Why are we going to watch Steven Seagal?
We got the real shit.
And then when you start watching real
dreams,
like you just download them,
boom.
Here's my shifts,
that movie that Juliette Lewis would,
if it was a dude was completely crazy
and you run,
you run the risk of becoming crazy by
following his dreams.
Like what?
There's a few dudes who are just
fucking.
Their dreams are so awesome.
You like,
I'll fucking risk it and you want to
ride dragons through the fucking cosmos
and share.
This guy has these ridiculous vivid
multicolor sorcerer.
When that,
when that technology has changed as the
Australian shades,
it's similar to that.
When you got that technology like
mastering your thoughts and your dreams
into DVD
combined with virtual reality
technology,
we're now you could get inside someone
else's dream and then they'll do real
time like,
like Web Cam Dreams,
like you go into their dreams as they're
dreaming.
Whether I should on that.
I was talking about from Gizmodo where
they recorded the dreams.
That's very close to that.
Well,
you know it's going to be.
They've already done it.
When they have.
I want to see what the fuck that looks
like.
What about when they figured out a way
to actually force you to dream?
What if they figured out a way to
trigger dreaming or if they figure out a
way to somehow or another they activate
something in your mind and whatever
chemicals that are released in whatever
situation becomes artificial,
like instantaneous,
you know,
they can make you dream.
See,
this video is showing what they recorded
from some from brain activity on the
right side while they're watching it.
Well,
the image of the fucking guy on the
right side is what the brain is seeing
on the left side is what the person's
watch and that.
That's incredible.
It's insane.
It's on Gizmodo.
It's under A.
There's a lot of people that are worried
about this.
Gizmodo,
scientists reconstruct brains visions
into digital video and that's a lot of
people are worried about this,
worried about this ultimate conversion
of people in machine and then it's
happening way quicker than we think it
is.
You know when,
when when you look up and you realize
that stuff like that has taken place
right under your nose and you didn't
know about it.
They're like,
oh my God,
like what is next?
What is next?
Somehow or another we're going to be
able to read each other's minds.
We're going to go right into each
other's brains and we're all going to
become one organism.
We're going to really recognize
ourselves as one and talking is going to
be fucking for,
for idiots.
Just going to be telepathy,
telepathy,
one-on-one.
They're going to run into people that
still talk.
We're going to be like Shannon ahead of
them living in the bush.
In Australia,
we like talking my and that all people,
but without any facial expressions,
you just laughing your head and that's
the time we could talk to the dolphins
and the animals.
I be Dr doolittle.
Do you think that's what aliens stand
for?
The archetype of the alien with the big
giant head and the big eyes and the the,
the emotionless face,
all that emotion outside is all just
necessarily only because we're shitty at
communicating and once we were able to
communicate completely through the mind
will need anything anymore out there.
So what do you think that represents?
It represents are inevitable.
Future are encoded end.
It's gotta be.
I wonder if that's just the way it goes.
Technology marches on and it makes
staggering pace if you look at us
compared to champs,
right?
I mean,
we're not done.
This is very,
it's very clear that human beings are
some sort of a work in progress.
And if you look at us compared to
chimps,
the big mystery in,
in the fossil record is the doubling of
the human brain size that it doubled
over a period of 2 million years.
And they don't know why.
They didn't know what it was.
But beyond that,
the old days,
no,
they were,
they wouldn't tell I'm.
It was too.
So they,
um,
if you
think about what,
what we became from the monkey origin,
the original,
you know,
lower prime,
what we became with our bigger head,
well if it's going to keep moving in
that same direction were going to have
big giant heads.
And if you look at the muscles that are
on champs and then you look at a scrawny
ass average American male who doesn't
exercise and just works on a fucking in
a cubicle all day,
they're there.
They're scrawny body is very much like
the scrawny body of an alien,
so if you keep going in that direction,
that's exactly what they come out like.
You come out like some fucking giant
brainiac with little twig limbs that
can't get anything done,
no Jujitsu at all,
no everything you've ever happened you
can get with without a facial expression
and let that a sound without a peep.
You can get all that.
You have so much fun just in your head.
You just go into other people's head and
you just like,
you know going to go into a trance and
you just get all this information and go
through all their memories.
You look at someone else and go through
their child and go,
man,
I love hanging out with you,
but in telepathy,
just going through everyone's life
window.
If that's darkness,
you learn to block your thought.
It'd be like the best restoration site
to Eddie's and just wonder if that's
what aliens on a wonder.
If aliens have figured out what they are
as real things that we're never going to
have real evidence about because they
don't exist in this dimension and they
interdimensional travel,
they just figured out how to tune into
different dimensions so they can come
here,
hang for a little while and fucking
Vamos,
but they do it in a way that almost as
undetectable or that our our,
our instruments can't really pick up
because they're not even from here,
so they'll show up as ghosts of disks
flying through the sky and we,
we barely registered because we're,
we're,
we're getting is like static.
It's like we're watching one station on
TV and it's not quite tuned in and
another one comes in and it's in
Mexican.
That's what we're getting.
We're getting like some,
some,
some bleed over from another dimension
and that's what Ufo is our.
Does Bob have a twitter?
Wouldn't that be cool to have one of
your shows?
I think he's full of Shit.
He might be.
He knows a lot.
He's fascinating,
but I almost wonder if that guy's
working for the government,
if he's disinflation agent because he,
um,
he lied about going to mit.
He lied to that shit that's like really
traceable,
you know,
but then he says that,
uh,
the government,
his records,
but that's not true because they found
school books from people who went to
school with him supposedly that were in
those classes and there's no bibles are
because there's old versions of the mean
the west.
They went back in time and altered,
you know,
every single one of the areas that the
government is not going to do,
that they would get hot.
So he didn't say anything like that.
Crazy.
He said he was like,
he said he saw like that could have
easily.
We already know that there's like German
Ufo is,
there's probably some American one that
he saw,
you know,
and it doesn't mean that it was alien as
kids.
We'd like some of US Air Force Ufo.
That's not what he's saying though.
What he's saying.
This is absolutely alien.
And the way when they were,
they were hired,
they were hired to back engineer it.
His whole story is,
if you don't know who Robert is,
Robert was our,
is a guy,
claimed to have worked
for area 51.
His story is he had this job there.
I became fascinated.
He was a scientist and they started
helping him.
He started helping them work with their.
They're they're aliens.
They had these or these alien spacecraft
that they had and they were trying to
reconstruct them,
but while this all was going on,
what they have to know everything you're
doing.
So they monitor all your phone calls and
they found out that his wife was
cheating on him and so they like,
oh,
this motherfucker is going to be
emotionally unstable.
We've got to kick them out of the
program because he's got turmoil in his
life.
So they fired him abruptly.
He didn't understand why they wouldn't
explain to him why they fired him.
And so the guy started bringing his
friends around to watch the UFOS get
launched and that's when he got
arrested.
And that's when he started telling a
story.
He started telling a story about how he
worked there and they hired him to
baggage.
It sounds awesome when you listen to
them talk and when he does,
when he breaks down science and all
these equations and using it.
I mean,
man,
he's an amazing liar.
If he doesn't know what the fuck he's
talking about,
but he's gone off with it.
He sends some incredible shit about
antigravity and all this crazy shit.
It almost makes me think that he's a
plant and that he's hired to do this
because it makes us look silly because
when you look into the guy and he says
all these fantastic things and then you
find out that he actually never really
went to mit and he lied about his past
and they can't find any record of him
anywhere and maybe he worked at Los
Alamos for,
you know,
who the fuck knows what he did there,
but he wasn't involved in any area.
50 one bullshit.
You know,
this is of course obviously what the
government says with it,
but it,
it makes him look ridiculous.
It makes them look silly.
If he lied about where he went to school
and so maybe if you wanted to end
speculation about,
you know,
at any particular area whether or not
Ufos were there,
you have some guy tell some crazy story
about it and then make sure that he's
full of shit.
Make sure he's full of shit about other
things.
So the people investigate when a
fantastical story they have to
investigate,
you know,
and they investigate and they find out
that he's full of shit and it makes the
whole thing seemed silly,
but we know for a fact they,
they,
they definitely test weapons there and
there's videos that people have shot
back before they,
they,
they extended the range of where it's,
you're prohibited to travel.
They used to be able to get much closer
to area 51,
but people would go to the certain Ridge
and they would film all these different
things flying through the air,
like the fucking crazy things taken.
All these right angle turns in the
middle of the sky.
And what most people think is that
that's where they were initially
practicing with drones and that those
things that were glowing in the sky,
the reason why they look like Ufo shows
is like this is the reason why they
moved so haphazardly,
threw this guy,
these roll radio controlled and they
really hadn't,
didn't have it down yet.
And we know now they have drones down to
a science,
you know.
And now the drone technology has gotten
to the point.
Yeah,
they killed that guy,
that American born a couple of them I
guess lot drones move like they like
those lights did a that they captured.
I don't know.
They seem to think so.
They seem to be just like model
airplanes.
Well let's think about what these drones
are for these drones carrying missiles.
They will just the weight alone,
if you have something that it's,
you know,
like say if you have something and it's,
you're,
you're flying around some magnetic
device,
some new next level antigravity fucking
ball of steel.
And we figured out how to pilot this
thing,
but it's not that accurate.
It works on magnetic waves when it's all
fucking nutty,
but it glows and it flies all around.
There's no one in it.
So can take crazy g force turns in the
sky.
It's very possible that that's a
completely different thing,
but that they learn from that and they,
they apply specific,
you know,
things that they learned from that into
these other drones to make.
But the other drones that they make are
often,
they're just based on,
you know,
uh,
artificially powered planes,
which they've had forever.
They've had.
And that was the part of operation
northwoods.
They were going to blow up a drone
plane.
They already had the ability to launch a
fucking plane into the sky just using a
remote control.
So I think that,
uh,
it's,
it's entirely possible that all that
shit that people saw around Nevada,
that's like things that the government
experiment not,
and that you have a guy like Robert
Lozar who comes in and says all this
crazy shit about Ufo goes and turns out
he's a liar.
And then it makes the whole idea of Ufo
is being there to be nonsense.
And then people just want to leave it
on.
I think it's more of a place where they
are.
They keep seeds,
keep certain.
Like animals.
Almost like a.
yeah,
like a civilization.
Why do you think that they have to do
that the government has to do now?
I mean don't you think they have like
they've already bought like seeds.
Why's that government has already bought
like almost every single possible,
you know.
And that's to keep it,
isn't it,
to keep it like pure to like always have
heard this.
Were you getting this information?
I don't know.
I saw something online about how the
government bought all the,
all the seeds.
So I'll have huge companies.
Noah's Ark situation or one company
bought all these seeds and they got
billions of seeds that they got stored.
Yeah,
that's like a news they got got Norway
to seed storage giant.
So they preparing for the end of the.
Yeah,
I think that's probably what it is.
You know,
it's like just to be in the middle of
the United States currently,
Norway has the biggest underground
bunkers to over 33 square miles.
That's the rumor.
Norway's the biggest ticket.
How's the rumor?
I can house a million.
A million for two years.
Really?
Yep.
Well I know there's some place in the
palm springs desert.
There's some guy,
they had them on TV and he was talking
about and they've set up apartments
there and people buy them a quarter
million bucks.
And you own an apartment under ground.
Oh yeah,
they have that.
You can find that shit on the Internet.
Did abandoned missile silos that they're
making like communities and shit and
they won't let just anybody.
I have a friend who actually looked into
it and wants to spend the money.
The problem is is you get there how you
going to get there when like a fucking
tidal wave comes or even if you.
Even if you could get there like you
bought.
There's like the communities that
they're building
and do you have to have some kind of
skill to have to even buy one?
Like how are you going to contribute to
this community?
So you've got to pass all these tests
and these interviews.
Yeah.
And then they take like 50 grand or
whatever.
Like when Shit goes down and I'm at the
front door,
are you going to open the Goddamn door
for me?
You know what I mean?
How do I.
The only way that would work is if
everyone had their own private entrance
and you add your own key to it,
you know what I mean?
But fuck,
you open up the door and then the horde
of zombies came in behind you and killed
everybody in the.
Yeah.
I could totally seem like don't fucking
open the door for nobody.
Shit went down.
Complex is.
Remember when you lived.
If you ever Linda apartment complex,
someone leaves the door open and people
get in and break into people's houses
and that's what happens.
Yeah.
Like that wouldn't trust that they'll
take your money.
Now that seems too sketchy.
Unless you live in it.
Last year a compound guy,
like you got a house,
like do you remember?
Um,
I don't know if you heard about this.
There was a house in Italy and they
suspected this guy of having some sort
of an underground military bunker
because he had moved a bunch of dirt out
of there and it had been years and years
of construction and so the Italian
government threatened him.
They're like,
dude,
we're going to burn your fucking house
down and kill you.
Like tell us what the fuck is going on
in your basement.
Like they were threatened by this guy.
Well,
they went into his basement and he had
this incredible artistically designed
temple.
There's all different styles of art.
When I say artistically designed,
it was.
It wasn't like by happenstance,
they.
It was like engineered and plan this
huge caverns like thousands and
thousands and thousands of square feet
and it's like one rooms and Egyptian
theme and the other room is in this
incredible other beautiful theme.
Was he preparing for the end of the
world?
I don't know what he built this fucking
thing under his house.
Like he built a whole different world
under his house.
It's amazing.
You know,
people are always trying to build things
and hide from people because they're
worried about the inevitable collapse.
Just get a nice spot down in the middle
of the earth.
Air is pumped up through a straw.
It definitely building bigger and bigger
bunkers and they're turning into cities.
That's just natural.
If I had all the,
if I was the ruler of the world,
I would just have people on the case
nonstop.
Keep building that shit deeper and
deeper and deeper.
Keep building it.
You know what I mean?
Because if you're running shit and you
have the power and unlimited resource to
build some safety,
of course it's natural human behavior.
It's the human condition to dig
underground and be safe.
If you could,
if you could have had all the money
shit,
just literally,
if you're doing that though,
you literally might be some of the last
people on Earth.
What a crazy responsibility that would
feel if you knew that the whole world
got wiped out,
but you were inside some fucking thing.
And uh,
there was a,
you know,
you,
you had a 90 percent chance and once you
got out,
the radiation had died down enough so
that you can survive.
You just got it.
We got to survive two years under there.
If you,
if the government came up to and said,
Joe,
we need you to keep your mouth shut.
You and your family can all come back to
you.
You got to pass.
We got the asteroid,
the asteroid gets comment,
but you just gotTa shut up about it.
It's can we just can't see it?
Everybody.
We can't fit everybody in.
You and your family just just
pipe down.
I never thought of it that way.
Like if you just do it,
if you were creating wonder who you want
to live with,
if you were creating a union family,
it might be better to just die.
It might be better to find out where the
asteroid's gonna hit and drive.
There
might be the movement living underground
with a bunch of fucking other second.
Naturally where we have that drive we
want to live.
I hope we're always reaching out no
matter what.
We're trying to learn responsibility to
keep this race going.
I never thought about it like involving,
if you're creating a noah's Ark,
what animals you would eat because you
wouldn't do every single animal.
You would keep the ones that were the
most important,
like chickens do nothing but buttons and
just ran.
It'd be chickens,
cows.
The idea of being able to actually hold
all the animals in one place is
ridiculous.
However,
the idea of being able to hold the
genetic information for all the animals
in one place is absolutely doable.
And so that's what if there was ever a
noah's Ark and the real life past of
humanity,
what it is,
probably a DNA bank and that at one
point in time,
you know,
there was a high level of intelligence.
That was when the Graham Hancock was on.
It was talking about,
uh,
intelligence,
the must have reached very high levels
and then got wiped out by some huge
natural disaster.
And then people were sort of left to
fend for themselves and kind of refigure
things out.
Some things never get figured out again,
man.
Some people reached a certain direction,
a certain level and they reached it in
Egypt and you know,
and 3000 BC and we still haven't hit
that yet.
Yeah,
that makes sense to me that,
that,
that makes a lot of sense to me.
You know,
I don't know that.
I mean I know that my genes would want
to keep going.
I would want to keep going.
I wouldn't want to put man.
What kind of a life with that being the
post apocalyptic life that would suck
up.
I would definitely do it.
I would want to.
I would try to live.
Yeah,
I think I would too.
I would to,
but fuck it would suck.
God Damn.
You were just supposed to try to make as
many babies as possible.
So you just had to find any girl.
You candidates come in and just like
that.
That'd be awesome.
Isn't it amazing that our terror
terrified world.
What's the terror of the terrified world
is that we would lose all of this.
We lose everything that we can bang on.
We could lose a houses and we'd be stuck
with just needing to forage for food.
He can't go to stores.
We don't have trucks and start over.
Everything.
Start over,
start over.
We're terrified of starting over.
Every other animal starts over every
fucking day of the week.
We're terrified of it.
We,
we,
we are so connected to devices and
inventions and technology that the idea
of being alone in nature forever is
fucking horrific.
That's horrific.
That's jail.
He'd rather go to jail and get fed four
square meals a day and at least if your
bunkie he's a good guy,
you know,
he can play chess together.
You know
what,
if you were allowed,
like if the government said,
okay,
we got one year,
this motherfucker is going to hit us.
Everybody build your own bunker in the
backyard and just everyone just started
building.
I'll go,
you know how you know how rich Mexicans
would be?
That'd be charged in a lot of money,
man.
Why?
Because that would be the ones doing it.
They'd be the ones that'd be charging
150 an hour.
They'd want their own bunker man.
They'd be like,
fuck you,
money doesn't mean anything with an
asteroid's coming,
and they tell you how deep it's gotta
be.
It's gotta be,
you know,
they already have their tunnels 30 yards
deep.
No,
it's common.
You got one year.
Everybody would be digging,
man.
They'd have instructions.
Everyone has their instructions from the
government.
Build your own shit.
You have a year.
Could you imagine if you were
underground and everyone's locked down
and you're all waiting as a countdown
and you know that it's supposed to
happen within the minute video,
cameras,
video,
cameras.
You're in a bunker and underground.
You just bump.
You're waiting for the impact of the
earth.
Just feel the whole thing.
Could you imagine what you say that the
one that killed the dinosaurs,
when it hit the earth,
it was five miles deep in the first,
second and a half,
the first,
second and a half and went five miles
deep into the earth,
and these are the same people that
measured the brain from that long,
from the caveman timer.
No regular done.
Those totally different types of
science.
You fuckhead they just talk about how,
what an impact that must have been like,
you know,
and if you were right there,
you're fucked.
But if you will on the other side and
your three mile deep bunker,
five miles deep,
Yo,
you know,
I do.
How much oxygen would you need for the,
you,
you'd have to have plants,
but would that even work?
Could you like have an environment
underground where you had plants and you
generated electricity so that you could
give the light sun,
artificial sunlight to the plants and
the plants cleaned up the carbon dioxide
that you breathed out and gave you
oxygen.
Would that be possible?
Could you develop an environment like
that?
I don't know.
I wonder if they could do that.
If they could figure out a way,
if there was a,
uh,
some method of power that they could
harness,
like say if they had some sort of an
underground reactor.
So they got this underground reactor and
they got this up for the fact that will
work for x amount of years and blah,
blah blah.
And they have a whole artificial world
down there.
And this reactor runs these lights and
it,
they make it rain on these plants and
the plants breathe in,
breathe out oxygen,
and we breathe out carbon dioxide and
they live off that chapter one.
Everyone makes their own underground
bunker and we've figured out a way like,
you know,
like we have a power source.
It's gonna last for,
for two years or whatever.
We could communicate with other people
on like these walkie talkies and shared.
And then you start digging to them and
you make like little tunnels to them and
shit.
Other people try to Jackie with their
time.
I was like,
dude,
I don't want you in my life.
Do just go back.
Boom.
Yeah.
What happens when they get like rabbits,
Jack and tunnels when people's towels
cross.
Put Gates on your toes.
Where does all the poop go?
People just show up and tell him,
no,
dude,
I live in a totally gay bars and these
guard gated tunnel.
That could be crazy.
Right?
Well,
it's possible.
It's underground man for breaking into
your shit all the time from underneath.
Terrible.
If the power goes out under there.
Oh,
what a horrible way to die,
you know,
you wouldn't have.
I wouldn't have a surrender is ready to
go for everyone in my family.
I'll have a syringe if some shit goes
down to shoot that motherfucker,
you know,
just go to sleep and just fuck it.
And on that note,
thanks Eddie.
We didn't even say your name.
Eddie Bravo.
We just started talking.
I want to be in Montreal in October,
late October.
I'm going to be a 10th planet Vista.
Go to Nibiru,
the Nibiru Forum at Tenth Planet J.
J Dot Com.
All my seminar information's there and
thank you very much.
What was that?
I had a special effect on the song from
Montreal coming.
You're so silly this Friday.
Houston,
Texas.
The verizon wireless theater.
But Brendan Walsh and Joey Diaz were
coming.
Correct?
We're slinging Dick and passing out
bubble gum as Joey Diaz would say.
Nice.
She got to walk on ice.
You might as well dance on St Louis in
November.
Um,
Australia.
Melbourne in December.
I'm going to do with your website.
They're not gonna.
Remember this?
Where's your website?
Tenth Planet j Dot j Dot Com.
Shizam go to the forum and those if you
looking for a place to train legends and
Hollywood is where it all goes down.
Come to California.
Where?
Where's the.
What's the address?
Fifty one 76 Santa Monica Boulevard.
It's on the east side of Hollywood.
Big Ass gym.
We got x poll there.
We got pulled dances,
we got a Jujitsu.
I teach you to Jitsu there.
That's 10 planet headquarters.
We've got an excellent kickboxing gym.
We've got an awesome NMA team.
Chris Riley is the MMA coach.
He's the head coach for the legends MMA
team.
It's even has creepy coed locker rooms.
Yeah,
so one of the real estate.
it's the weirdest shit of all time and
strippers or training,
training with the animals.
It's done on purpose.
The dudes are taken gnarly shit and they
get out and girls are waiting to get in
there.
I have more than one time taking a
gnarly shit and then you get out in some
poor girls waiting to get in there and
the bathroom like.
All right,
good luck with that.
Good luck.
We had.
We actually,
I didn't know this until recently,
but we actually have the biggest strip
pole class,
like we have the longest poles.
That's what he said.
And uh,
I didn't know that.
I didn't know we had the most ultimate
goal dancing school ensured to the gills
from chicks falling on their heads
prize.
It doesn't happen,
but that Anderson Cooper thing,
Anderson Cooper's got a new daytime talk
show and he had some kid doing some
skateboard stunt.
The kid fell on his head and he's in
critical condition.
Oh,
she's fucked up.
The producers like,
show something crazy.
I know you can do something crazy.
So the kid does something crazy and
falls and lands on his fucking head on
the show.
We didn't use it.
They didn't air it,
but they did it for the show.
Wow.
Don't listen to Anderson Cooper.
Okay.
If he tells you to get crazy,
think about what you're doing.
That's all I got to say.
The loop.
I missed the loop fucking shows over
folks.
Thank you to the flashlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net,
click on the link for the entering
the code name.
Rogan,
you'll get 15 percent off the number one
sex toy for men,
and if you're looking for Alpha brain,
go to Onnit,
o n n I t dot Com.
And entering the codename Brogan.
Save 10 percent.
I'm saving you money on your loads and
your brain.
That's it.
Show's over.
We may have one tomorrow.
I don't know.
I got to.
We've got to find a suitable guest.
And you're gonna be a comedy juice at
the melrose.
Oh yeah.
Tomorrow.
Comedy juice.
The Melrose Improv tomorrow night.
I don't usually advertise that shit son.
I just show up.
I'll be in an ice house Thursday.
Go,
go crazy.
You can tell jokes.
I'm gonna.
Be there with red shift.
And Freddy Lockhart for comedy Jews at
10 PM.
Oh,
Thursday at the ice house.
The small room is the shit in the main
room.
Big Room.
That's the small rooms.
I'm in love with that small room.
That 85 seater.
We're going to be there a lot more
often.
Ladies and gentlemen,
thanks for everything.
Thank you.
Everybody came out to DC and wherever
the fuck else I was denver.
And um,
we've been having a lot of fun and uh,
this weekend show ideas and Brendan
Walsh at the verizon wireless some
tickets still available.
We're ready to come.
And then the next night.
So the UFC.
Oh,
it's going to be crazy.
UFC too.
Thank you.
Eddie Bravo.
Thank you very much.
J Dot Com.
Oh Shit.
Shizam.